So, auf gehts.
So, wunderbar, auf gehts.
Leute, Massive, Big Brain Chat, ich muss euch mal was fragen, und zwar, habt ihr das
mitbekommen mit diesem einen Ruby Jam, was irgendwie 50.000 Billiarden Repos kaputt
gemacht hat. Das ist das gleiche, was letztens NPM hatte, vor ein paar Jahren. Und zwar,
eigentlich wieder recht lustig gewesen. Okay, das ist wieder Musik, die nicht weiß, ob sie
laut oder leise sein soll. Genau, und das ist wieder so ein typischer Fall von selbstverkackt,
ne. Also, bei NPM war es ja kompletter Witz. Bei NPM hatten sie das vor ein paar Jahren,
da hat man ein Paket unpublished und es hat irgendwie 50.000.000 Projekte kaputt gemacht,
ne. Und ich mein, man darf nicht vergessen, es gibt bei NPM Packages für is odd, is odd
or even Packages. Ich mein, hallo, warum brauch ich eine Library für ist eine Zahl gerade
oder ungeradet? Wenn's ja da nur schon in der Sprache eingebaute Konstrukte gäbe, um
das rauszubekommen. Naja, das waren die Probleme bei NPM und Ruby hatte jetzt ähnliche Probleme,
da hat auch einer ein Paket zurückgezogen und es hat irgendwie 50.000 Projekte kaputt
gemacht. Das ist echt wieder übels Fell. Der russische Typ, das ist hier Cacomodates.
Der da. Cacomodates, any Cacomodates. Ist klar, jetzt mal kurz spannen, CacWade. Ja,
ja. Weg. Die Lippa hat 30, 300 Lines. Ja, Moment, die Ruby Library oder das da? Das
da hat nicht so viele Lines, das hat 20 oder so, das hab ich letztens irgendwo gesehen.
Ja, Ruby, die macht ja auch eine halbwegs sinnvolle Geschichte, die Ruby Library, das
ist nicht so ein Schwachsinn wie das von NPM. By the way, ich muss euch mal was zu C++
fragen, Leute. Habt ihr eine Ahnung, warum? Habt ihr eine Ahnung, warum, ich muss eh
nicht vor allem anmachen, warum folgende Sachen in C++ keinen Warning, warum es keinen
Error gibt, kann ich verstehen, aber warum es keinen Compiler Warning gibt? Also, mach
mal hier auf, das dauert ja so ewig lang. Also, warum gibt das hier in C++ keinen Warning?
Vielleicht weiß das jemand. Guck mal. Warum gibt das keinen, nicht zumindest einen Compiler
Warning? Muss man das verstehen oder ist das einfach C++-Dinger? Also, mal nur zur Erklärung,
warum es einen Warning geben sollte oder geben könnte, ist, man sagt ja hier explizit, negative
Zahlen sind nicht erlaubt. Das heißt, minus 1 ist in Wirklichkeit nicht minus 1, sondern
plus, plus der Maximalwert von der Geschichte. Warum gibt man hier nicht zumindest mal einen
Warning aus und sagt, wahrscheinlich willst du da nicht minus 1 reinschreiben? Weiß nicht,
warum es da keinen Warning gibt. Verstehe ich nicht. By the way, wir müssen, ach guck
mal, meine VM ist da, null. Jetzt brauche ich sie auch nicht mehr. Wir müssen uns eine
Windows VM installieren. Mal schauen, habe ich hier noch irgendwas? Ach nee, es gibt,
habe ich wieder diesen scheiß Bug mit is in use. Oh nee, ich habe wieder diesen Bug, VM
is in use, Alter. Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn? Das hatte ich doch gestern schon. Na gut,
aber eine neue VM können wir wahrscheinlich anlegen, da kann man ja wohl nichts dagegen
sagen. Wir brauchen eine neue Windows VM, weil ich will mir den Kram nicht unbedingt, ich
weiß gar nicht, ob ich WSL hier drauf habe. Ja, das ist noch das Einser. Also ich installiere
mir auf jeden Fall neue Windows VM zum Ausprobieren. Und die Sache ist die, warum ich das mal ausprobieren
will mit WSL ist folgendes. Was war jetzt an der Message so schlimm? Ach, er wollte
den Timeout. Jetzt verstehe ich es auch. Stimmt, man kann sich ja Timeouten lassen mit 2500
Channelpunkte. Exzellent, exzellent. Ist doch viel leichter hinzuschreiben als nach einem
Max, ja, was auch möglich wäre. Warum gibt es denn nicht sowas? Warum gibt es denn nicht
sowas? Vielleicht so. Oder, oder. Irgendwas, keine Ahnung, es ist C++, muss man nicht
verstehen, aber warum ist das wieder überhaupt Ding? Da ist er ja wieder. Was moin Max, du
glaubst gar nicht, wie gerne ich deine Videos auf YouTube schaue und mir. Ja, ist doch nice.
Ich meine, vielleicht guckst du die Videos ja auch nicht nur, weil du sie früher gerne
geguckt hast, sondern guckst sie immer noch gerne. Das wäre mir natürlich, natürlich
noch lieber, ja. So, ich installiere mir mal nebenbei eine Windows VM, die brauchen wir
jetzt, bevor wir anfangen können. Also, wer das nicht kennt, WSL ist ja diese Geschichte,
wo man Linux unter Windows installieren kann. Und nicht wie ich das hier mache, in der VM,
sondern quasi, man könnte sagen, WSL war früher so das Reverse Wine, also quasi man
hat Linux unter Windows laufen lassen und nicht Windows unter Linux. Und jetzt ist es
mittlerweile so, im Prinzip ist WSL 2 auch nur noch eine VM, aber noch eine VM mit irgendwie
spezieller Config. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Die Sache ist plus die. Microsoft ist
da relativ committed, was das angeht und bastelt da ziemlich viel dran rum. Und warum ich das
jetzt ausprobieren wollte mit WSL, also WSL 2, nicht das normale WSL, warum ich das mal
wieder ausprobieren will, ist folgendes und zwar, bei uns auf der Arbeit haben sie sich
überlegt, wir bekommen demnächst alle Windows VMs verpasst, die wir benutzen sollen. Also,
das hindert mich nicht daran, irgendetwas anderes zu benutzen noch, aber sie haben sich
überlegt, es ist eine gute Idee, es kriegen alle Windows VMs und mit diesen Windows VMs
kann man dann Dinge machen oder auch nicht. Und ich hab mir jetzt mal gedacht, ich guck
mir jetzt mal auf Spaß an eine Freundin, ich guck mir das ja immerhin regelmäßig im Abstand
an und das ist auch schon benutzbar, ein paar Dinge sind halt nervig. Zum Beispiel, dass
man grafische GUI Sachen nur schlecht verwenden kann. Ich weiß nicht, ob das mittlerweile
besser ist, aber ich brauch halt GUI Applikationen unter Linux, zum Beispiel eine IDE, um irgendwas
zu entwickeln oder zumindest mal einen ordentlichen Editor oder so. Ja, mal gucken. Was sollt ihr
denn mit Windows VMs machen? Ja, das ist witzig, die haben sich bei uns nämlich überlegt,
das ist natürlich eine berechtigte Frage, ich hab das auch nicht verstanden und die
haben sich jetzt gedacht, alle Leute, die für Linux-Systeme zuständig sind, wenn die remote
arbeiten wollen, dann sollen die erst mal gar keine großartigen Rechte bekommen, sondern
alle Leute, die für Linux-Systeme zuständig sind, bekommen eine Windows-VM gestellt, von
der sie dann Zugriff auf ihre Linux-Systeme bekommen. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man auf
die Klonreiche Ideen... Ist das VDI? Ja, das ist... Wie spricht man Citrix geil aus? Cytrix?
Cytrix? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Gibt es eine coole Aussprache von Citrix? Cytrix? Cytrix?
Ich muss noch gucken, wie man das offiziell... Cytrux, was? Citrix, ja, das wissen wir schon,
das wissen wir schon, aber... Es wäre schon cooler, wenn man das Cytrix aussprechen
könnte oder so, ne? RDPX installieren, ja, probier ich alles aus, probier ich alles aus,
mal gucken. Die Sache ist die, ich brauch's ja aktuell gar nicht so wirklich, ne? Also,
VM? VM? Postchamp? Wie wär's mit sich beenden, VM, please? Chat, wer von euch
war's? Wer hat's meine VM kaputt gemacht? Seid ihr schon drin? Ah, nee, die VM hat sich
ja beendet. Sehr gut. Okay, neue VM... Achso, ich zeig euch... Ich hab, by the way, das
ist immer noch die alte VM-Version, bevor mich wieder einer drauf hinweist und nachdem
er gesagt hat, mach's, upgrade doch mal. Ja, jetzt, wenn ich mir schon Key gekauft hab...
Ich hab mir aber keinen Key für... Also, schon ein bisschen länger her. Aber, wie gesagt,
ich erwähne ja immer, dass ich mir bei so einem super vertrauenswürdigen Software-Shop
vor allem Key gekauft hab für 22 Euro oder 25 Euro. Und ich find's geil, die funktionieren
auch wirklich. Oh nein, es muss jetzt keiner in Chat posten, man findet auch anderweitig
Key. Das ist mir klar, aber das will ich jetzt hier nicht großartig zeigen, ne? Mein OBS
ist auch übrigens voll up to date mit 24. So, und ich zeig euch jetzt mal den Trick,
den alle immer geil finden, den zeig ich in jedem Stream. Windows 10 ISO downloaden funktioniert
nicht, weil man nur updaten kann. So, es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Entweder man
geht von der Linux-Kiste drauf, dann kann man das downloaden. Oder man kann einfach faken,
dass man von einem Mobilgerät drauf zugreift auf die Seite. Jetzt geht man nämlich hier
in die Ansicht vom iPad, refresh die Seite und schon kann man die ISO downloaden vom
aktuellen Windows 10. Den Trick hab ich schon 30 Millionen mal gezeigt, aber der Chat mag
den Trick jedes Mal. OBS ist doch schon mal 26, ja OBS ist schon. Ja ne, richtige Hacker
mein Trick. Der Chat ist immer begeistert von dem Trick. Microsoft Entwickler hassen
diesen Trick. Du wirst nicht glauben, was dieser YouTuber macht. Microsoft Entwickler
hassen diesen Trick. HTML Hack, genau. Oh ja, Windows auf Arabisch, das wollte ich ja immer
mal installieren. Englisch International. Oder das Media Creation Tool geht natürlich
auch. Jetzt kann man übrigens auch hier wieder raus machen, dann kann man runterladen. Ihh,
das ist Platoon Musik, oder? Ich glaube ich bin der Einzige auf der Welt, das Platoon
Musik nicht mag. Oh, huge download speed. Massive Geschwindigkeit. Massive Geschwindigkeit.
Ok jetzt gehts los. Microsoft hat sich gedacht, ok wir warten 55 Sekunden und jetzt kriegste
vollen Speed. Diesen Trick kennt nicht mal Bill Gates. Das ist ein guter Titel. Diesen
Windows Trick kennt nicht mal Bill Gates. Ich vermute mal Bill Gates kennt mittlerweile
die wenigsten Windows Tricks. Ich frag mich ja ob Bill Gates überhaupt selbst noch Windows
verwendet. 32-Bit, na das ist ganz klar. Ich hab nur einen 64-Bit Prozessor, deswegen nehme
ich, ne das ergibt keinen Sinn was ich sagen wollte. Brain lag. Aber heißt das denn dann
man könnte, man könnte mit einem 64-Bit Prozessor, könnte man dann 2x 32-Bit Windows laufen
lassen? Oh, also quasi 2x Windows auf einem Core, weil 32-Bit und 32-Bit. Das ist ungefähr
genauso viel wie FPS das männliche Auge sehen kann. Da wissen wir, dass es 12 plus 12 ist
für jedes Auge 1, also für jedes Auge 12. Deswegen ist 24 das Maximum an FPS was man
sieht aber auch nur mit beiden Augen auf. So ungefähr verhält sich das glaube ich mit
2x 32-Bit Windows unter 64-Bit CPUs. Bill Gates macht hinten Features and Tricks in Windows
Videos. Das ist natürlich auch eine Frage, kann man mit 2x 32-Bit Cores einen 64-Bit Betriebssystem
Single Core laufen lassen dann? Fragen über Fragen. So ist der Kram jetzt nicht runtergeladen.
Aber legen wir schon mal Windows Geschichte an. Vm. Next. Next. Next. Windows 10. Next.
Nein, und nicht hier, sondern unter. Postchamp. Unter. E. Vms. Delete me. Oh, dass ich das
nicht vergesse nachher wieder wegzuschmeißen. Next. UEFI, ja meinetwegen. Wenn das die Fall
für Windows ist meinetwegen. 3 Cores sollten, ach komm scheiß drauf, 4 Cores Windows braucht
das. Ich hab genug CPUkerne. Und 8G. Ach nee, das kann man hier gar nicht machen. Was ist
das? Oh, ich kann mir das immer nicht merken. 8100, 96, 92. Ich kann das, ich kann alles
von 1 bis 4096. Des 8000er kann ich mir immer nicht merken. Wobei das eigentlich, da sieht
man mal wie Boomer ich bin. Mittlerweile ist es eigentlich fast schon wichtiger. Man
weiß alles oberhalb von 256. Weil drunter brauchen wir eh net. Nee, 8G anklicken geht
nicht gescheit. Also, oh doch. Ich dachte mal, man kann das anklicken. What the fuck.
Ich hab immer gedacht man kann da nur sliden. Wusstet ihr das, dass man das anklicken kann?
Ich hab da immer nur geslider antet. Ich bin nur Sliderman gemacht. Und man kann da
vorne draufklicken, das ist genau 8192. Cake wait. Wusste ich nicht. So, bam. Ja, not,
next. Was? NVM, ja pff meinetwegen. Create new disk, 60G, single file, bam, bababam.
So und der Drucker raus. Weiß ja nicht warum da immer standardmäßig ein Drucker drin
ist. Leute kennt noch einer das Problem, wo wir gerade beim Thema Drucker sind. Während
hier das erstmal in. Was? Nein. Genau, also was wollte ich jetzt sagen zu Drucker. Also
ich brauch meinen Drucker genau einmal im Jahr, wenn ich nämlich für den Steuerberater
ein paar Sachen ausdrucken muss. Hi, hab einen Dankeschön für den Zapp. Nämlich wenn
ich für den Steuerberater ein paar Sachen ausdrucken muss, weil der bewahrt die Sachen
ja bei sich auf. Und machen wir gerade VM in der VM? Nee, nee, nee, machen wir nicht.
Und jedes Jahr ist meine Tinte eingekrustet. Und ich hab mir schon überlegt, sollte ich
mir vielleicht mal einen Drucker kaufen, wo Tintenkrusten halt nicht eingeht. Also halt
kein Tintenschralldrucker. Auf der anderen Seite bin ich halt der Meinung, ich drucke
so wenig, es lohnt sich eigentlich überhaupt nicht einen neuen Drucker zu kaufen. Hat irgendwie
einer so richtig nice einen Trick, wie Tinte nicht mal einkrustet oder so. WSL läuft doch
im Hyper-V oder nicht? Ja, hast recht, wir machen VM in der VM, ja. Aber das funktioniert.
Das haben wir vor einem Jahr schon mal probiert, das funktioniert. Das einzige was man machen
muss, stimmt, gut dass ihr es sagt, das einzige was man machen muss, das hier muss man einschalten.
Sekunde, das muss ich einschalten, sonst funktioniert es nämlich nicht. Gut, dass wir drüber gesprochen
haben Chat. Hi IQ Chat wieder. Ich muss ihm sagen, wir wollen das da machen. Porn. Dann
mounten wir mal das Windows ISO. Achso, das ist das CD Laufwerk, jetzt checke ich das
erst. ISO Image. Windows 10 ist der Kram. Ist der Download fertig jetzt? Ja. Connect.
Jetzt die Stade. Windows install, auf gehts. Bäm. Das geht ja mittlerweile relativ schnell,
vor allem aus dem laufenden System raus. Alter Business Laser Drucker, wie funktioniert
das? Die Idee ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Warum schickst du deine Unterlagen nicht per
Mail zum Steuerberater? Das ist eigentlich eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, das liegt zum
größten Teil daran, weil ich so eine Mischung aus Real Life Beiträgen, Real Life Zettel
habe, wo ich keinen Bock habe, die umgedreht dann einzuscannen und elektronischen Sachen.
Das darf German. Next. Install now. Jawoll. Was kosten sowas? Was kosten sowas hier?
Laser Drucker, so ein alten Brother oder so. Was? 34 Euro? Achso, ohne Toner, ohne Toner.
Moment, Moment. Keg Weight. Das kann nicht funktionieren. Ich will irgendwas für 20
Euro, so ein billiges Ding. Das kann ich dann in die Abstellkamera stellen und einmal im
Jahr drucke ich da. Den stelle ich hier gar nicht ins Büro rein. Boah, das ist ja ein
uralt fettes Ding. Das ist ja, das wiegt ja schon 100 Kilo alleine. Im Surferraum habe
ich leider keinen Platz mehr. Normalerweise würde ich ja sagen, ich stelle das hier in
meine Abstellkamera, also Schrägstrich-Surferraum, aber wie ihr seht, da ist ja kein Platz mehr.
Wo soll ich den Drucker hinstellen? Down of the Earth, da komme ich dann mal rein. Da
ist kein Platz mehr. Schraub den Drucker an die Decke, die Decke
ist ziemlich hoch in dem Raum. Was, Laserjet? Rocky ist Schoki, drei Monate, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Von der Decke, nee das funktioniert. Ich weiß, dass G-Bade ist, aber ich denke
ja manchmal auch an so abgedrehten Sachen, aber das klappt nicht richtig. Image of the
day drucken, einmal im Monat, ja das ist eine gute Idee, da rostest du dich ein. Kannst
du deine E3-Config im Discord hochladen? Nee, du kannst aber auf mein GitHub gucken, da
ist die E3-Config. Boah, das ist ja noch ein altes, fettes, fetteres Teil. Aber wisst
ihr, was wir machen könnten, was fällt mir gerade an? Wie schwer sind denn so Dinger?
Nehmen wir mal den hier, was hat das Teil für ein Gewicht? Während Windows hier am,
boah, gehste fort. Nein, ich hab kein Produktkey. Was übrigens lustig ist, dass wir mittlerweile,
früher musste man da immer, äh, by the way, hab ich euch mal erzählt, ich kannte den Windows
98 Produktkey auswendig, weil ich es in der damaligen Zeit so oft neu installiert hab.
Heute kannst du einfach klicken, ich hab kein Key und es geht trotzdem weiter. Okay, next.
Äh ja, next. Wie alt bist du? 36. So, ähm, wie viel wiegt denn sowas hier? Gewicht? Kilogramm?
Wo ist das, das steht doch da meist. Sag mal, hat eBay nicht normalerweise eine längere
Artikel, eine ordentliche Artikelbeschreibung immer gehabt? Ah. Vollständige Information.
Vollständige, hä? Was kosten sowas? Gewicht, die Dinger, so die alten Business-Dinger sind
immer massive, fett. Okay, sagen wir mal aufgerundet mit Papier und allem drin, mein Papier wiegen,
ja, aber ich sag mal aufgerundet mit allem 20 Kilo. Ähm, ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Da müsste ich ja hier quasi ein Regal machen, und hier hängt schon was an der Wand, da müsste
ich hier nebentran ein Regal machen, was groß genug ist und 20 Kilo aushält, dauerhaft.
Ne. Ne, ich glaub, das ist keine so gute Idee. Dann stell ich den lieber in die andere
Abstellkammer, kommt ein Raspberry Pi als Drucker so einfach dran und einmal im Jahr
wird gedruckt. Weil, ganz ehrlich, wozu Drucker mit W-Lan-Funktionen kaufen, wenn man einfach
über den Raspberry Pi irgendwie drucken kann. Einfach den Drucker 3D drucken, ah yes. Der
hat Netzwerk, ja aber ich hab kein Netzwerk in meiner Abstellkammer. Also ich muss das
in irgendeiner Art und Weise eh bridgen. Sag mal, weiß jemand, ob das funktioniert, wenn
man nen Drucker hat? Johnny, was? Leak? Ne, ich wollt grad sagen, ne, ich kann das nicht
aussprechen, langsam. Wie sprich man das aus? Johnny Yekoto, zwei Monate lang, ich schüffel
den Sub. Massive Subscriptions, hrq für den Chat wieder hier. Bessere Abstellkammer,
sehr agiler Name, äußerst Agile. Mario XCB, Massive Sub, zwei Monate. Ah ja, gut, wenn
wir uns das noch am installieren, sehr schön. Und der Switch im Rack in der Abstellkammer,
das ist nicht die Abstellkammer, das ist meine Säuferraum-Abstellkammer. Ich hab noch ne
normale Abstellkammer, da würd ich den Drucker reinstellen. Hier ist ja kein Platz für
den Drucker. Hier wäre das auch kein Problem. Hat jemand eine Ahnung, ob das, ob man gescheit
von einem iPad oder generell von Tablets oder sagen wir mal von IOS-Geräten drucken kann?
Ähm, zu einem Raspberry Pi Druckerserver, gibt's da irgendwie was? Wie nennen sich
da Kram noch mal AirPrint oder AirPrint? AirPrint. Raspberry Pi Print-Server, Kubs und AirPrint
einrichten. Alter, die Musik! Ach, Dings. Ok, das funktioniert schon mal gut. Ich hab
noch einen. Geht das Ding denn unter Linux überhaupt? Bevor ich mir sowas alles kaufe,
öhm, Open Printing, der funktioniert mit Linux. Die Frage ist jetzt nur, trau ich dem
Chat, wenn er sowas sagt. Was ist denn die offizielle Homepage von denen? Das da. Ähm,
Support. Ok, ich muss mal kurz den Darkreader ausmachen, die Seite sieht. Uah, Flashbang!
Sonnenbrille auf, äh. Sag mal. Sag mal, bin nur ich das oder sieht die Seite wirklich
echt scheiße aus? So mit kaputter Schrift und sowas? Die sieht so kacke aus, ok. Die
für Baneschap, das ist richtige Baneschap-Seite. Jetzt geht der Darkreader wieder an auf Flashbang.
Ok, Global Download Sender. So und jetzt lasst mich, Global Download Sender auf. Lasst mich
mal suchen nach dem Modell. Gibt schlimmere Seiten. Das hier sieht jetzt auch wieder ok
aus, aber das andere ist wirklich, äh, Europe. Wobei, ist doch eigentlich egal, oder? Für
Driver Download ist doch vollkommen egal. Search Product hier. Da isser. Ähm, Linux
Driver. Linux Packages, als was gibt's das? Naja. What? Als Target Set. Was ist ok, Moment.
Was ist denn dann da drinnen? Also erst mal Trial MB Driver oder sowas. Warum ist das
so groß? Na gut, dass das ganze Postscript gibt, aber trotzdem. Alter, what the fuck.
Vielleicht geht's auch einfach, wenn man's anschließt, weil der Driver dabei ist. Weil
das hätte echt nen Charme. So ein All is Office Ding. Druckt der denn überhaupt noch?
Ist da alles dabei? Alle mit Toner. Der Download ist lahm, das lassen wir bleiben. Aber das
ist ne gute Idee. Ich find, das ist ne gute Idee. Was kostenbar sowas versandt? Kostenlos.
Ach, nice. Cool. Weil, ich glaub mir, ich hol mir so ein alles Ding. Mein Tintenstrahltrucker
geht mir extrem auf den Sack. Ich mein, mein Tintenstrahltrucker hat zwar den Vorteil,
der hat direkt Airprint und WLAN Geschiss drinne, aber, ähm, ja, yes, yes, yes, ist
korrekt. Aber, des Eingrusten geht mir voll auf den Sack. Ich druck damit so wenig und
die Farbe brauche ich druck damit ja keine Fotos oder sowas. Kann sich noch jemand an
die Zeiten erinnern, wo man voll im Trend war und so ein super High-Res-Farb-Tintenstrahltrucker
hatte und sich dann extra Fotopapier gekauft hat, dann ne halbe Stunde gedruckt hat und
neben dem Drucker gesessen hat und die Millimeter geguckt hat, wie das Papier rauskommt. Und
dann hat man sich gefreut, dass man eben so ein nice, äh, nice Quality auf Fotopapier
hatte, was im Prinzip voll von Arsch war. Wenn ich wirklich gute Quali will, dann lass
ich mir das professionell machen und ich drucke im Prinzip nie Farbe, jetzt auch nicht. Ich
hab noch nichtmal Farbe drin in meinem Drucker. Ich hab nur Schwarz-Weiß-Patronen gekauft
vom Trittanbieter. Aber das Einrosten und jedes Mal Kalibrieren und so geht mir voll
auf den Sack. Ich will einfach einmal im Jahr, wenn ich Steuererklärungs-Sachen mache, für
den Steuerberater ein paar Sachen ausdrucken. Das ist dann auch nicht viel. Lass es mal
20-30 Seiten sein. Einfach irgendwelche Belege noch mal raushauen und das dann, ich will
einfach drucken können, ohne mir Gedanken machen zu müssen. Okay, das ist so ein typisches
Windows-Ding, was ich wieder nicht kapier. Guck mal. Der hat mich 5 Mal gefragt und ich
hab gesagt, ich bin in Germany. Ich hab German Currency. Warum schlägt ihr mir standardmäßig
jetzt Keyboard-Layout United Kingdom vor? Warum nicht einfach Germany? Und warum kann
ich hier drinnen nicht G drücken für Germany? Was denkt sich Microsoft bei solchen Dingern?
Paints-Champ. Zum Glück ist es nicht auf Französisch standardmäßig.
Du hast alle Level 1 Emotes gesammelt. Wow, nice. Steht grad bei mir in Twitch.
Das heißt, du musst Multicast-Forboding machen, wenn Wi-Fi und Drucker an unterschiedlichen
Subnetzen sind. Nee, das passt ja. Deswegen würde ich auch ein Raspberry Pi ins WLAN
hängen. Direkt an den Drucker dran. Das würde ich ja irgendwie bridgeen oder so. Mal gucken.
Bin schon nicht ganz sicher. So, what do you like to set up for personal use? Next. Jetzt
sagt er gleich Microsoft-Account. Das ist auch wieder so typisch. Das ist auch wieder
so eine richtig krasse Microsoft-Debate-Geschichte. Let's add an account. Und du denkst dir ja
schon mal nichts Böses und sagst dann, lul, weh, bla, bla, bla. Und dann sagst du next.
Und dann sagt er, hä? Valid email-Attress. Ah, der erstellt ein Microsoft-Account. Dann
muss man erst hier unten auf offline-Account drücken. Dann sagt er, oh nein, wollen Sie
sicher einen offline-Account? Ja, ich will eine limited experience haben. By the way,
was ist eigentlich limited an dieser experience? Außer, dass ich weniger Sachen an Microsoft
schick? Gute Frage. Kannst du was zu sagen? Einfachster Weg, um einen Windows-Server extern
erreichbar zu machen. Also das erste, was ich machen würde, ist gar nicht. Ich würde
einen Windows-Server niemals ins Internet stellen. Es sei denn, du hast wirklich sehr
gute Gründe für das zu machen. Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon aus, die hast du
und willst das wirklich machen. Also die einfachste, die beste Variante, einen Windows-Server
ins Internet zu bringen, ist, einen Linux-Server davor zu stellen. So. Aber wenn du das wirklich
machen willst, dann ist die Frage, hast du eine statische IP, dann ist die Frage easy,
da musst du gar nichts machen, außer Port weiterleiten. In der Regel kannst du eigentlich
nur Dynamik-DNS machen. Der Anbieter ist egal. Du kannst hier einen Duck-DNS machen, du kannst
über Cloudflare-DNS-Dinger machen oder so. Du musst aber halt auf jeden Fall Ports weiterleiten.
Und ich würde es nicht machen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich würde es nicht machen. Aber wenn du es
unbedingt machen willst, dann ist DNS und im Heimbereich die einfachste Variante. Ich
meine, auch wenn Kabelanschlüsse so gut wie statisch sind mittlerweile, aber die wechseln
doch mal. Werdet du es elf Monate, du bist eins vor Hyper-Subscriber. Dankeschön für
den Sub. Und wie läuft es bei euch? Wird gebashed? Hoffe ich mal, dass es gebashed wird. Ich
hab gesehen, ihr sucht zwei neue Leute. Vielleicht doch nicht so gebashed. Keine Ahnung. Aber
ich hoffe, es läuft alles gut bei euch. Static-IP ist ja meistens sinnlos daheim. Dir bleibt
nichts anderes übers wie das über DNS zu machen. Aber ehrlich, ich würde keinen Windows-Server
ans Internet stellen. Hey Maxi Schreiber, Montag eine Online- und IT-Rechtsklausur. Hast du
irgendwelche Tipps? Ich hab von Online- und IT-Rechtsklausur keine Ahnung. Nee, hab ich
nicht. Ok, Local-Account-Test. Dienstag ist VCT. Was ist denn VCT? Valorant? Tournament?
Valorant? Was ist denn das C? Contenders Tournament? Nee, keine Ahnung. Champions Tour. Ah. Ok.
Chat, ihr werdet nie mein Passwort erraten, was ich vergeben hab. Da kommt ihr nicht drauf.
Wie habt ihr das erraten? Wie konntet ihr das Passwort erraten, Chat? Ist doch gar nicht
möglich. Hallo123? Die Story mit, ne doch die Hallo123-Story hab ich ja schon erzählt,
ne? Wo ich mal bei GMX nen Account fast verloren hab, weil ich Hallo123 hatte. Ist aber schon
Jahre her. Or even better use an Online-Account. Nein. 1. Mein erstes Haus, die hieß 1. Ich
bin in der Stadt 2 geboren und mein Nickname früher war nicht etwa Max oder so oder Maxi
oder sonst wie. Nein, sondern 3. Letztens war ich im Freien. Es kommt immer noch vor,
also mal an frischer Luft, ja. Und da hat ne Mutter ihr Kind gerufen und das Kind hieß
Maximilian Tiberius. Dachte ich mir, ok. So vor 2000 Jahren im alten Rom wäre der glaube
ich voll im Trend gewesen. Also das ist so ein typischer Römername. Wobei es wahrscheinlich
eher Maximus wäre bei den Römern. Maximus Tiberius. Maximus, ne warte mal, wie hieß
der Gladiator? Maximus Dezimus Meridius, glaube ne. Maximus Dezimus Meridius, wie hieß der
Gladiator? Maximus, verstands doch. Maximus Dezimus Meridius war der Gladiator, genau.
So n Scheiß merke ich mir, ne? Weil ich gestern gegessen hab, weiß ich schon immer. Lollongos
Schwanzos. Bigges Dickes. Ich muss ja ehrlich sagen, die Sachen sind ganz witzig, aber
so diesen, den riesen Kultfilmhype um die Sachen versteh ich nicht. Die sind ganz witzig
teilweise, aber jetzt so der Brüller einer, ich weiß es nicht. Also vielleicht ist einfach
nicht so 100% Schweinhumor. Nein, wir wollen keine Speech Recognition haben. Wir wollen
auch nicht die Location sharen. Wir wollen auch nicht mein Device finden. Wir wollen
auch, übrigens das ist auch immer was tolles im Windows Setup. Man kann nicht, man kann
nicht einfach sagen, ich will nichts zu Microsoft schicken. Diese Sachen, also diese Option
gibt es nicht. Also es gibt bloß die Option, ich will wichtige Sachen schicken und zusätzliche
Sachen oder ich will nur die wichtigen Sachen schicken. Ne Option, ich will gar nichts an
Microsoft schicken ist nicht im Scope, wie man so schön sagt. Das gibt's net. Nein,
ich will das nicht improven, ich will auch nix da. Alter, das ist so ätzend, dieses
rumgeklick am Anfang immer. Es gibt A-Entschließungsinstall Speedruns gibt's. Echt? Zeig mal, da muss
mir ein Link schicken, das müssen wir uns angucken. Nein, Cortana. Hallo. Früher hat
Cortana jetzt immer angefangen zu labern. Zum Glück ist das vorbei. Hi, I'm Cortana.
Zum Glück shuttet die ab mittlerweile bei der Installation. So, ich werde das da einrichten,
ich wollte gerade noch mal Chat lesen. Also, ne, kann ich dir nichts zu sagen, ich hab keine
Ahnung von online und IT Recht. Die labert nur in der Pro nicht mehr. Ernsthaft, ist
Cortana in der Home Version noch am Start? Was würden eure Consultants auf die Frage
beantworten? Ich weiß gar nicht mal, um was es geht, deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht beantworten.
Das ist das Problem, also sobald mit dem Chat hinten dran ist. Ja, wer hat das noch mal
gefragt mit dem Windows Server? TroM. Kann da jetzt noch eine Begründung, warum er seinen
Windows Server ins Internet stellen will? Richtige Hexer setzen gar keinen Passwort,
ich glaub das geht nicht. Bis denn, machs gut. Ja, jetzt wo du es sagst, ich überlegs mir
noch mal. Das, ja, ich versteh auch, ich, ganz ehrlich, das wäre mir viel zu anstrengend,
wenn ich mein Kind immer Maximilian Tiberius rufen würde. Das würd ich nur machen, wenn
er was angestellt hat. Ich würd, ich würd den wahrscheinlich, ich, ich, also, ich würd
mein Kind schon mal auch aus Prinzip nicht, nicht Max nennen. Das fänd ich irgendwie
blöd. Max Junior oder so dann. Höchstens als Zweitname oder so, eventuell. Ich, ich
würd den dann immer so nennen, wenn er was angestellt hat. Aber ansonsten, und ich würd
mein Kind wahrscheinlich auch nicht Tiberius nennen. Arch Linux Installation Speedrun,
das gibt es ernsthaft? Okay, das muss man zwar, das geht nur zwei Minuten, das müssen
wir uns jetzt mal schnell angucken, während Windows installiert. Da, da, ich seh da aber
noch einiges an Optimierungspotenzial. Und ob das die optimale Route ist, weiß ich, mag
ich auch zu bezweifeln. Und das ist das der Weltrekord? Playback Speed is increased. Das
ist gecheatet. Und außerdem der hat keine Splits? Der hat keine Splits? Oh, ohne Splits
keine Speedruns. Was, was? Echo, was? Ah, W. Ah, der, der, der macht äh, Partitionierung.
Das ist, das ist die, das ist die Big Brain Variante, ne Festplatte zu Partitionieren,
was der Typ da grad treibt. Ah, das ist langweilig, aber das kann man sicherlich noch optimieren.
Ich glaub, ich glaube, ich glaube, da werd ich auch mal nen Speedrun Attempt machen.
Aber mit richtig echtem Splits. Arch Linux Speedrun World Record Pace. Hier ist, der
hier ist 1.10 Realtime. Hier. Ok, jetzt gehts los. Arch Speedrun World, World Record. Ok
Moment, kurz, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss die Tippgeräusche hören. Moment, das ist
in der VM, wo er das macht, aber ok, würd ich auch machen. Der hat aber Splits, immerhin
hat er Splits, oder nicht wirklich Splits, aber nen Counter. Äh, Corsair RGB Tastatur
muss schon mal sein. Wow. Ok, der hat schon mal nen bisschen anderen Pace drauf als der
Rest. Der, der macht es richtig. Das, man kann nämlich schon den Befehl eintippen, den
er danach ausführen soll, während der Installation, also während das andere Kommando läuft, kann
man schon weiter tippen, das geht. Guckt der da oben ab? Ich glaub, da oben schreibt
er, da schreibt er ab. Aber was ja auch legitim ist. Genauso musst du es machen, schon den
restlichen Scheiß eingeben, bevor die Installer, genau, und dann ausführen, direkt wenn die
Installer fertig ist. Siehste, das hat er alle schon eingetippt vorher. Und jetzt BÄM. Das
ist ja schon hier Arch Linux Speedrun Install in einer Minute 10. Der hier ist auch krass.
Leute, ihr vergesst, ich hab nen Addon, was mir anzeigen lassen kann, welche Links was
es gibt. Da hab ich sofort erkannt, dass das ein Recroll ist. Nen Wupploh aus. So, ist
Windows da, jawoll. Ihh, Edge. Das ist so ne Windows Logi, frisch installiert, ne, und
schon am meckern über irgendwas, was... Windows, was willst du von mir überhaupt? Edge ist
PangeChamp. Ja, wir müssen erstmal schnell auf Vmware Tools installieren, dass ich das
Ding im Vollscreen hab. Auf, auf, Vmware Tools, gib alles. Ja, install. Setup64exe hört sich
immer sehr vertrauenserweckend an, wenn man den ISO mountet und es dich fragt, ob du Setup64exe
wieder ausführen willst. Next, next, next, jawoll, ach so Musik anmachen. Wir hatten
letztens, wo wir gerade bei Internet Explorer sind, wir haben so ne richtige PangeChamp
Zeiterfassung auf der Arbeit. Die ist richtig PangeChamp, die sieht doch aus wie 1995,
ne? Wahrscheinlich ist die von 1995. Und die haben sie geupgraded. Kennen die noch im Silverlight?
Klar, klar. Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt erzählen? Genau, also, die haben sie geupgraded, die
sah jetzt immer noch aus wie 1995, die Zeiterfassung Software, aber sie haben ein bisschen was
am Layout geändert und das hat Kompatibilität mit dem Internet Explorer kaputt gemacht und
die mussten ernsthaft das Update zurückrollen, weil sich Leute beschwert haben, die Seite
würde nicht mal so aussehen wie sie das kennen. Das muss man sich echt mal vorstellen. Also
wir haben Leute, die benutzen täglich bei uns auf der Arbeit noch den Internet Explorer.
Das ist schon PangeChamp, oder? Ich weiß gar nicht, was die da wollen. Und dann, das
sind die gleichen Leute, die sich da drüber beschweren. Ho, Windows fühlt sich aber wieder
so langsam an. Nein, das ist nicht Windows, was sich langsam anfühlt. Das ist der Internet
Explorer, der nicht zurecht kommt mit modernen Webseiten. Ja, Bubble bringt ja bei CSS aber
nix. So, da sind wir. Bäm, installiert. FPS Anzahl, klar. Komm, man muss schon wissen,
guck mal, wir aktualisieren gerade unseren Windows Desktop mit. Gucken, ob ich das schneller
hinkriege. Pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt Microsoft Desktop Aktualisierung Speedrun. Oh nee. Moment,
wir müssen vorher noch eine Sache machen. Exclusive Mode, sonst packts rum. Auf wieviel
Herz? 60 Herz. Bäm, vielleicht krieg ich schneller hin. Das kommt mehr als 60. Wieviel
Herz gehen wir maximal? 64, 64. Gib alles, gib alles. 63. Arme tut weh. So, wunderbar,
63. Gib es vielleicht so besser hin. Wusstest du gar nicht, dass die Vmware Grafik hatte
mehr als 60? Kann? Ich auch nicht, wahrscheinlich ist das einfach nur eine Anzeige-Bug gewesen.
Wieviel kann? Steht das hier irgendwie? Wieviel die maximal kann? Das ist mal, Leute, ich
bin mittlerweile unfähig. Ach hier, kannst du die... Ich weiß nicht mal, wo ich überhaupt
Refresh Rate einstellen würde. Hier, 60, mehr geht nicht. Da steht aber einstellen.
So, also, jetzt erst mal dieses Windows Ding weg und als erste Amtshandlung, die wir machen
müssen, ist... Nein, erste Amtshandlung, die wir machen müssen, ist Chrome runterladen,
oder Firefox, oder was auch immer. So, wir nehmen Chrome, aber please den englischen
Chrome, nicht den deutschen. Falsch, wir richten ein MS-Konto ein. Okay, wenn der Chat
unbedingt Firefox will, machen wir Firefox. Warum kommt als erstes Opera, wenn man nach
Firefox sucht? Ah ja, von Chip natürlich. Ich will aber den Firefox nicht als DE runterladen,
sondern schon als US, genau. Okay, Firefox Installer. Moin, Kengin. Nee, N-Nightzackt.
Was heißt Zackt? Mag ich nicht. Ich benutze eigentlich zum größten Teil nur Scoop für
Sachen zum installieren und ansonsten klassische Windows rumgeklicken.
So, jetzt kann ich den Edge gleich wegmachen. So, Firefox installiert, zack. Bam. So, wie
stellt man nochmal die Fault-Apps um? So ging das, glaub. Die Fault-Mail-App für Browser.
Wisst ihr, was ich geil finde? Das ist alles Taktik von Microsoft, Leute. Ich sag's euch.
Ich weiß, man kann hier als Use-Default machen. Die haben den Browser als allerletztes unten
und das haben die garantiert, dass die meisten Leute es nicht sehen, in der Hoffnung, sie
verwenden weiter Edge. Nein. Geh mal nicht auf den Zack-Switch. Dazu kann ich nur sagen,
Microsoft. Und jetzt erstmal unpin löschen. Okay, jetzt können wir, jetzt können wir,
jetzt kann wir nichts mehr machen. Also, ehrlich gesagt, ich vergesse jedes Mal, wie man jetzt,
wie man WSL 2 installiert. Ich muss das jedes Mal nachgucken, weil das ist ja nicht so einfach
wie WSL irgendwie installieren. Früher musste man da, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das
immer noch musste, man musste in Turn Windows Features on off und dann musste man in, da
muss man hier in den Häkchen hin machen. Keine Ahnung, ob das immer noch so ist. Wir gucken
uns mal das offizielle How-To an. Muss immer noch als Feature aktivieren. By the way, wenn
ihr mal kecken wollt, ein Telnet Client ist unter Windows ein additional Feature, was
man erst über das alte Systemsteuerungsmenü aktivieren muss. Ja, ist ja auch ganz schön
und das war es zu einem Telnet Client. Kann man nicht erwarten, dass er dabei ist. Ist
er eigentlich Candy Crush und das gedürnt es noch drauf? Oder installiert er es in der
Pro-Version nicht mehr? Das ist so viel Mist, ehrlich gesagt, da schon wieder dabei, was
ich nicht verwende. Paint 3D. Gibt es überhaupt irgendjemand, der wirklich Paint 3D verwendet?
Also ich verwende Lull 3D, aber nicht Paint 3D. Firefox oder Chrome, was ist besser? Ich
bin langjähriger Firefox Fan und ich verwende unter Linux eigentlich auch immer noch standardmäßig
Firefox, aber ich muss sagen, für den täglichen Gebrauch hat Chrome bei mir auf dem Desktop
Firefox abgelöst. Firefox hat immer noch den Vorteil, dass ich die Adressleiste standardmäßig
besser finde, weil die Historie Favoriten und alles Mögliche durchsucht und man da teilweise
Seiten findet, wo man vor 10 Jahren mal drauf gewesen ist. Das ist wirklich nice. Aber alles
in allem muss ich sagen, gefällt mir das Handling vom Chrome besser. Geschwindigkeitsmäßig
würde ich sagen, ist der Chrome auch ein bisschen besser, wobei sich das Ganze nicht
allzu viel nimmt. Schwer zu sagen. Hat beides seine Daseinsberechtigung. Ich mag halt Firefox,
also Firefox hat mich, wisst ihr, ab wann ich gesagt habe, ich verwende auf dem Desktop
kein Firefox mehr, beziehungsweise stimmt ja, ich verwende ja auf dem Desktop noch Firefox,
wann ich gesagt habe, ich verwende auf meiner Standardinstallation kein Firefox mehr. Das
war zu Firefox, ich glaube 48 oder so oder 58, wo sie die, wo sie die Pluginschnittstellen
abgeschaltet haben. Firefox 59, was 59? Able old addons, mit was kam das denn? Ist das
noch zufällig jemand? Ich glaube, ich glaube, das war, ich glaube, das war 58. Nee, 58,
das ist zu kurz, das muss, muss schon ein bisschen länger gewesen sein. 48. Zumindest
haben sie es da geschafft, NoScript kaputt zu machen und NoScript war für mich damals,
äh, ah hier, Firefox 48 war es, genau. So und die haben quasi NoScript komplett kaputt
gemacht. Das war Firefox 48, ja, genau, genau. Da haben sie nämlich auch was zugeschrieben.
Genau, das war 48 und das Problem war, ich, ich habe das damals für absolut notwendig
gehalten, dass man NoScript verwendet. Ich finde das immer noch notwendig, aber es gibt
damit mittlerweile ein paar einfache Dinge zu handhaben. NoScript musstest du jede einzelne
Seite erlauben, sonst wie. Mittlerweile gibt es NoScript, doch es gibt wieder NoScript,
wobei ich nicht weiß, ob es jemals wieder so nice funktioniert hat, wie die alten NoScript
Varianten unter Firefox 48. Das weiß ich nicht mehr, weil es ging eine ganze Weile NoScript
nicht richtig und deswegen habe ich gesagt, scheiß drauf, wenn die so einen Kack machen,
kann ich auch Gleichchrom verwenden. Ist U-Matrix nicht tot? Ich weiß nicht, ob das tot ist.
Das ist anscheinend tot, doch. Warum? Ja, aber das wird nicht mehr geupdatet, warum nicht?
Ach so Moment, New Tracker. Ist der Support eingestellt? Ich weiß, dass es, ich habe das
gesehen, aber die meisten schreiben ja wenigstens noch was hin, warum das eingestellt ist.
Grip U-Matrix, okay. U-Matrix. Hat er sich da geäußert irgendwie?
I don't have time to work on U-Matrix. Okay, ja, Grip. Zu viele negative Kommentare von
der Community. Ey, das wäre ein Punkt, also wenn das der Fall wäre, das könnte ich tatsächlich
verstehen, weil die Community, die Leute sind teilweise echt undankbar, gerade in Open
Source Projekten und was immer witzig ist, der, na gut, wer auch immer übelst angepisst
ist, ist der VLC-Maintainer, der kriegt auch immer richtig dumme Kommentare und es gibt
jedes Jahr eine Diskussion um den Weihnachtshut. Das ist richtig Pain's Champ, Leute. Wenn
ihr mal richtige, nervige Pain's Champ-Menschen auf einem Haufen sehen wollt, lest euch die
Formthread im VLC zu dem Weihnachtsmann-Hut durch. Das ist extrem Pain's Champ, das geht
über mehrere, das ist übrigens das Falsche, es gibt noch mehr Diskussionen, die teilweise
bis ins letzte Jahr gehen und sowas. Das ist Massive Pain's Champ. Mir ist nicht richtig
verständlich, wie man sich an einem Weihnachtsmann-Hut stören kann. Ja, ich habe auch manchmal
das Gefühl, ich kann nicht verstehen, wie man solche Probleme haben kann. Hat VLC immer
noch dieses altbackende UI? Ja. Aber das funktioniert ganz gut. Es ist halt wirklich
voll der Witz. Zumal man sogar in den Settings ausschalten kann. Aber ich verstehe gar nicht,
warum man über sowas diskutieren muss. Das ist einzig und allein die Entscheidung von
dem, der den Kram entwickelt. Und wenn der sagt, er will da einen Weihnachtsmann-Hut
drinne haben, dann hat er halt einen Weihnachtsmann-Hut drinne. Ich reg mich auch nicht auf darüber,
auch wenn ich der ungläubigste Typ auf der Welt bin wahrscheinlich. Ich reg mich auch
nicht über den Santa-Hat auf, ich würde mich auch nicht darüber aufregen, wenn der Typ
sich da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, das Spaghetti Monster oder sowas. Das wäre mir vollkommen
egal. Ich würde die Software verwenden und im Zweifelsfall würde ich es abschalten,
wenn es mich zu sehr nervt. Naja. Hast du mal das geplante neue UI von VLC gesehen?
Nein, habe ich nicht. Warum gibt es auf omg-ubuntu eine Anleitung, how to install vsl 2? Weil
es obuntu ist wahrscheinlich, ne? Standardmäßig. Sorry, nicht obuntu, ich werde es korrekt
aussprechen, ich habe recht. Jubantu natürlich. Das ist der aktuelle Zeitgeist gerade. Lilo,
das ist der aktuelle Zeitgeist gerade. Man ist überall empört. Das ist leider aktuell so.
Egal was es ist, Leute sind überall über jeden Scheiß und jeden Furz empört. Und natürlich
geht man lieber ins Forum und hatet rum, anstatt das Icon einfach abzustellen. So, also wie
geht es jetzt? Install vsl 2 on Windows 10, sage ich her. Omg, jubantu. Ich will wissen,
ob das immer noch so funktioniert, wie ich mir das, wie ich das, über das Feature Menü
Enable vsl, ah PowerShell. PowerShell ist jetzt der neueste Shit, ok? Ok, das ist im Prinzip
das gleiche, was ich über Skui gemacht hätte. Wir machen das jetzt über PowerShell. Coole
Leute machen das. Leute, wisst ihr was wir vorher machen? Ballade die 3 Monate Dankeschön
für den Sub. Exzellent Subscription. Um nichts zu sagen. Massive. Das Ubuntu tutorial ist
für Anfang 2000. vsl 2, Microsoft können wir auch gucken. Was ich machen will, wir
installieren jetzt das neue Windows Terminal erstmal. Ne ne ne ne, das neue, wir machen
heute Microsoft Only. Windows Terminal, wir installieren das neue Windows Terminal. Das
neue, worüber man sich ja eigentlich schon, da sieht man mal, wenn so ein Projekt 72.000
Sterne kriegt, für ein Terminal, was im Prinzip immer noch schlechter ist, also nur nach 15,
nur nach 15 Linux Terminal, sieht man mal wie painstampig das alte Terminal eigentlich war.
Ich meine, das hier ist ja nur wirklich eine Beleidigung für jeden, der im Terminal was
tippen will. Ja, es gibt ein neues. This repo-cont, install and running. Man kann über GitHub
installieren, aber den Microsoft Store, ok, wir gehen in den Microsoft Store, herunterladen,
jawoll. Ich hoffe, ich brauch dafür keinen Microsoft Account. Get, hallo, get. No, einfach
runterladen. You own this app, sehr schön, dass ich die owne. Ein, aha, einfach abbrechen,
null. Launch. Jetzt pinnen. So, da haben wir das neue Microsoft Terminal. Standardmäßig
auch schon eine PowerShell am Start, sehr gut. So muss das sein. Chat gucken, ich glaube,
ich hab nicht irgendwas übersehen. Shithub, genau. Ja, wie gesagt, es gibt ein neues,
das ist benutzbar im Vergleich zu dem alten wenigstens. Ich glaube schon, dass bei WSL
die Ubuntu Leute mit dabei sind. Ja, bin ich für mal ein, dass ich das auch irgendwo
gelesen hab. Chrome oder Chromium? Das hier ist ein Chromium. Aber ganz ehrlich, dem Standard-User
würde ich tatsächlich ein Chrome empfehlen, weil gerade für Windows, da gibt es Security
Updates einen Ticken schneller aus wirklich richtig offiziellen Google-Quellen und so Sachen
wie GPU-Beschleunigung und sowas funktionieren, was bei mir hier Probleme macht. WinGet kann
immer noch nicht den selenialen Microsoft, ey. Also Windows ist wirklich in manchen Belangen
zehn Jahre plus hinter Linux. Umgedreht ist Linux auch in vielen Belangen zehn Jahre
plus hinter Windows. Leider gibt es noch nicht das perfekte Betriebssystem für alles. Deswegen
ist es ganz einfach, einfach den Linux installieren in der VM, so wie hier, und rüberswitchen.
Easy. Beste Variante. Windows Host und Mac OS, nee, auch nicht wirklich. Du hast unter
Temple OS kommt der Sache am nächsten, ja. Du hast unter Mac OS zwar den Vorteil, dass
du viele Unix-like-Programme verwenden kannst, standardmäßig einen ziemlich alten Varianten,
aber gibt's ja auch zum Updaten. Dafür hast du halt schlicht und ergreifend viele Windows-Software
nicht. Also sprich, du hast beispielsweise keinerlei Spiele. Wie hast du deine Taskbar
so geändert? Gar nicht, das ist die komplette Default-Taskbar. Ich hab das Ding gerade frisch
installiert. So, also wie geht das Ganze jetzt? Installieren das WS des Windows-Subsystems?
Wir machen das nach der Ubuntu-Anleitung, die wissen, wie das geht. So. Also, Enable.
Dism. Alles klar. M. Wir müssen als erstes in diesem Terminal nochmal ordentlich was
einstellen. Settings. Was? Ich muss eine extra App für Settings installieren? Ach,
das ist Jason-Settings-Files, oder? Ach so. EGit Notepad. Ich wollte eigentlich nur den
Font ändern. Wie kann ich den Font ändern? Scheint schon wieder hochkomplex zu sein.
By the way, warum hat Windows eigentlich nicht einen standardmäßig gescheiten Editor dabei?
Ich mein, die haben doch jetzt VS Code am Start. Installieren wir auch nochmal, wo wir
gerade dabei sind. Wo wir gerade dabei sind. Komm. By the way, hat irgendjemand eine plausible
Erklärung dafür, warum es Wishlist Studio Code nicht im Microsoft-Store gibt? Wenn ich
auf VS Code suche, bekomme ich hier Heartbeat Romance Club. Warum gibt's den Kram nicht
im, warum gibt's den, warum gibt's das nicht im Store? Sagt Microsoft dadurch nicht quasi
indirekt, fuck den Windows-Store? Microsoft Romance Club. Ja, das glaube ich auch, die
wissen selbst, dass der Store scheiße ist. Wishlist Studio selbst und sowas geht ja auch
nicht über den Store, wobei es gerade dafür sinnvoll wäre, den Kram zu updaten. So, kann
ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt Settings von meinem Terminal ändern? Wishlist Studio Code exquisite.
Okay, wie, jetzt gibt's die große Preisfrage. Windows Terminal Font. Wie kann man, wie kann
man die, wie kann man hier die Schriftart und Größe und so ändern? Hat das ein Autocomplete
oder sowas? Ah ja, anscheinend Autocomplete, okay. Also, Format, nee. Font, hm. Tja. Font,
geht schon mal nicht. Font, äh, gibt's anscheinend nicht. Okay. New Windows Terminal, Change
Font. Einstellungen aufmachen, das sind die Einstellungen, die haben kein Einstellungsmenü
mehr. Was unter Profiles? Was? Profiles? Ah, hier. Ah, put settings here that you want
to apply for all, okay. Font. Ah, Font Face. Cascadia Mono, ist das Standard, ne? Okay,
hat das, hat das hier Autocomplete? Nee, natürlich nicht. Aber Hack, ich hab Hack nicht installiert.
Hack Font. Oh, what? Okay, probier mal Font, Font Size aus, 20. Wow. Thick. Wenigstens
updatet es gleich. Oh, 16. Bam. So, so mag ich das. 14. So, okay, wir lassen jetzt den
Default von, ich wollt bloß mal gucken, wie man da was umstellt. Also, WSL installieren,
bam. Oh. Ach nee, ich muss, Moment, ich muss als Admin starten. Ich muss als Admin, kann
man hier raus direkt was als Admin starten? Nee, ne? Siehste mal, das wär zum Beispiel
ne sinnvolle Funktion, die es anscheinend so standardmäßig net gibt. Das heißt, ich
muss jetzt den Kram komplett als Admin starten, oder wie? Pass Control und Shift. Okay, ich
muss mal gucken. Okay. Features werden enabled, sehr schön. So, enable virtual machine platform
requires, alles klar. Wir haben ein neues Window, das passt. M, X. Hack Font, Hack Font
ist der beste, seh ich auch so. Okay. Was gesudo? Das ist was, was man nachinstallieren
muss, oder? Wahrscheinlich. Wir installieren jetzt mal Package Manager und Ordentlichen
für Windows, install methods, jawoll. Und dann installieren wir was, gesudo. Boah, das
ist schon wieder so ein richtiges Rumgefrickel hier. Was? Ah ja. Es jit, jit muss ich installieren.
Okay. Was gesudo? Ey, das gibt's da wirklich. Gesudo und dann, und dann wie? Und dann was?
Und dann Explorer, oder was? Ah. Okay, das ist in der Tat ganz praktisch. Kann ich da
auch Kommando-Zeilen-Programme damit ausführen? Also sagen wir mir ls, gesudo ls. Hey, das
ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich. Ein ordentliches Sudo für Windows, das ist ja mal richtig
poggers. Nice. Okay, können wir weitermachen mit WSL? Also, das haben wir gemacht. Enable
virtual machine, set WSL als Default. Gesudo, machen wir das jetzt einfach mal hier so.
Aber dass er jedes Mal fragt, ist auch schon echt ätzend. Oh. Was ist kaputt? Muss ich
doch als Admin ausführen noch mal? Muss man rebooten? Stand das da, dass man rebooten
muss? Restart your system. Na gut. Warum haben die dann bei dem letzten Kommando no restart
angegeben, wenn man doch danach eh restarten muss? Winnerslogik. Egal, wir rebooten mal
eine Runde. So muss das sein. Exquisite Reboot. Was ist besser? Das Emote, wo er sich nicht
bewegt oder wo er sich bewegt? Weil eins von beiden will ich rausschmeißen. Beide brauchen
nur nicht. Wo er sich bewegt, ist besser, oder? Ich hätte ja gerne die Fast Food Variante
mit Animation. Die würde ich sofort reinnehmen. Die würde ich sofort reinnehmen, wenn es
sie mit Animation gäbe. So. Und jetzt? Wie geht's weiter? WSL. Was stehen wir? WSL
Default Version. Und jetzt? Please Wizard. Okay. Wie macht man links hier auf? Wie machst
du denn dieses Swipen in der VM? Was meinste? Du meinst das Wechseln zwischen Host und VM?
Ctrl, Alt, Pfeil rechts, Pfeil links. Ich hab auf dem Desktop meine VM und hier den
anderen Kram und ich kann einfach mit Tasten Kombination wechseln. Okay, wie installier
ich jetzt? Warum ist das hier nicht Science and Technology, weil ich nicht umgestellt
hab? Ja, Splixer kann ich, das kann ich alles machen. Das ist bloß die Frage, wo das steht.
Also mal angenommen, ich hätte jetzt keinen Chat, der mir helfen kann. Ah, Please Wizard
Kernel. Okay, das haben wir gemacht. By the way, warum kann er nicht einfach den alten
Kernel starten und dann sich upgraden und selbst downloaden? Okay, es ist Windows, das
darf man nicht zu viel erwarten in der Richtung. Paints Jap. Ja. Ja, hab ich gemacht. Okay
und jetzt? Darf ich jetzt? Ah, yes. Sehr schön. Muss ich eigentlich überhaupt mit
Sudo machen müssen? Nee, anscheinend nicht. Okay, passt, es ist ja gerade installiert.
Set WSL2 as your default version, install your Linux distribution of choice. Okay, das
heißt, jetzt geht man in den Store und sucht... Was ist denn da oben los? Was will der denn
von mir? Wenigstens kein Candy Crush am Start. So und jetzt Ubuntu. By the way, warum lädt
er den Kram? Okay, den Sinn muss mir jetzt mal einer erklären. Man lädt das über den
Microsoft Store runter, aber die Sache updaten kann man nicht über den Microsoft Store.
Das muss man nicht verstehen. Ubuntu 20.04, jawoll, komm her. 20.04 LTS. Moment, was
ist, was ist das hier? 9 Euro Virtualisierungskram. Ich bin ja immer begeistert, wie viel Schrott
es im Windows Store gibt. Powerful Simply Virtual Machine. Ist das, ist das ein Frontend
für Virtual Box? Er scheint mir recht Paynes-champig zu sein. Was, run Mac on Windows? Äh. Run
Mac on Windows, okay. Das ist, das ist gar maß. Wir haben es ja schon mal ausprobiert.
Vielleicht auch ein Hyper-V-Freund, wir haben es ja schon mal ausprobiert. Mac läuft virtualisiert.
Naja, man kann Sachen drin ausprobieren, aber schön ist es nicht. Was ist Reft? Ist
das auch hier ein Distro, oder? What the fuck? Es ist schon mal geil, ne? Bevor steht, was
es ist, bevor da steht, was es ist, ist erstmal Payment. Ein Distribution Manager. Warum soll
ich ein Abo kaufen für einen Windows WSL Distribution Manager? Warum denn Abo? Was ist denn da wieder
los, ey? Eine Güte. Okay, also jetzt sollen wir den Kram hier installieren. Okay, machen
wir. Gucken, ob wir auf der richtigen Seite rausgekommen sind. Also ein hässlicheres
Logo hätten sie ja nicht nehmen können, oder? Also ein hässlicheres Logo, wirklich. Ist
das mal ernsthaft. Das sieht aus, als hätte es irgendjemand mit Paint 3D gebaut. Wahrscheinlich
war mit ihm verboten, das mit Paint zu bauen. Das ist, das ist das normale Ubuntu Logo
kopiert auf einen absolut unpassenden blauen Hintergrund. Nein. Sieht aus, sieht aus wie
ein Scam Download, ja? Echt so. Okay, Ubuntu wird installiert. Get. Install Windows Termin,
das haben wir schon gemacht, haben wir schon gemacht. Geh weg. Genau, mal gucken, ob der
das automatisch erkennt jetzt. Ups, ah. Okay, ich schließe, ich schließe das nochmal.
Ich schließe das nochmal. Gucken, ob der jetzt automatisches WSL erkennt. Nein. Das
wäre ja auch deutlich zu einfach, wenn er das automatisch mitkriegen würde. Oder vielleicht
muss ich WSL auch einmalig starten. Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem WSL Kommando?
WSL und Ubuntu. Wo bekomme ich raus, wo das liegt? Gar nicht. Ah, okay. Ubuntu, Installing.
Alles klar, auf geht's. Während es installiert. Genau, also ich muss sagen, es ist mittlerweile
nicht mehr ganz so schlimm, aber eine ordentliche Linux Installation ist mir immer noch lieber.
Es ist cool, dafür ist es tatsächlich gut, wenn man Windows Sachen und Linux Sachen besser
verknüpfen will, also wenn man beispielsweise einen Explorer starten will aus einer Linux
Shell oder so. Ja, dafür ist es cool. Aber ansonsten, ich bevorzuge immer nochmal Linux
für M. Geh sudo credentials cache. Probieren wir gleich noch aus. Unix name. Test. 123456.
123456. Jawoll. Installierst du dann als nächstes PowerShell unter WSL 2? Können
wir das nicht machen? Kann man Wein installieren? Nee, oder? Das heißt, wir könnten Wein installieren
und dann in Y Notepad ausführen. Okay, erst mal sudo update. Achso, ich wollte ja gucken,
ob das, wir machen erst nochmal ein Upgrade. Ich wollte ja mal gucken, ob das jetzt in
dem neuen Windows Terminal drin ist. Wir installieren da nun mal ein Wein und führen da drüber
was aus. Das wird grausam. Wir führen da ein Notepad über Wein in Windows aus. Scheint
zu funktionen, jetzt probieren wir gleich mal aus. So, erst mal updaten. Was passiert
hier? Wir gucken uns WSL 2 an, ob das immer noch sagt. Beziehungsweise, ob man damit beispielsweise
als grafische Programmegescheit verwenden kann. Ich gucke mir das einmal im Jahr oder
so an. Okay, wir haben geupdatet. Wie sieht es aus? Ist es jetzt hier drin? Da ist es.
Da ist es, Leute. Seht ihr es? Eben war die Frage, wie ich das mit dem TTS mache, mit
dem Text-to-Speech. Ich habe hier so eine eigene Sache gebastelt. Das ist quasi mein
Stream Deck, selbst gebaute Stream Deck-Lite-Geschichte. Da sind ein paar Bildchen drin. Die GIF-Animation
ist in dem Fall übrigens viel zu schnell, wobei sie hier funktioniert. Und das steuere
ich vom anderen Bildschirm aus. Ich habe ein paar Shortcuts mit Steuerung L, kann ich zum
Beispiel LUL machen und sowas. 3 ist LUL, 3D, M ist MonkaS. Mehr habe ich, glaube ich,
gar nicht belegt. Aber ich mache das zum größten Teil eh nur darüber, über das Dashboard.
Max, weißt du, warum man für Grafana Prometheus braucht? Braucht man nicht? Brauchst du nicht?
Achso, naja. Deine Frage, ich weiß, was du meinst, aber die passt, also in dem Kontext
ergibt es keinen Sinn, weil Grafana selbst braucht verschiedene Quellen, die es versteht,
aus dem es Grafen generieren kann. Prometheus ist eines von diesen Quellen. Prometheus und
Grafana haben miteinander nichts zu tun. Die Metriken, die du abrufst, sind Prometheus-Metriken,
die Grafana versteht. Also beziehungsweise die Grafana kann über die Prometheus-AP dann
drauf zugreifen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre Grafana und Prometheus von den
gleichen Leuten. Du kannst beispielsweise 30 verschiedene, Grafana unterstützt 30
verschiedene Quellen, also du kannst Influx DB nehmen oder aber, wenn du beispielsweise
Influx DB nimmst, dann kannst du auch Grafana weglassen und denen ihre eigene Geschichte
verwenden. Die haben so ein Grafana-Lite eingebaut mittlerweile schon, oder was heißt eingebaut,
mit dabei. Also wenn du Influx DB verwendest, die haben so ein eigenes Grafana-Ding dabei,
wobei ich dir ehrlich sagen muss, hier so ein Teil, wobei ich dir ehrlich sagen muss,
mir ist Grafana lieber als der Krempel. Und dementsprechend, wie gesagt, Grafana greift
nur auf verschiedene Datenbanken zu und visualisiert das, dann einen HTTP-Server abfragen, würde
ja bedeuten, dass Grafana ein eigenes Metrik-Format bräuchte, was man da abrufen kann. Aber Grafana
nimmt ja nur das, was schon da ist. Kann man auch machen. Weil das ja nicht dann Kibana
ist, sondern das ist ja dann der Elk-Stack, weil man mittlerweile alles einen coolen Namen
braucht. Kibana ist out, der Elk-Stack ist jetzt ja. Nein, kein Splatoon-Musik, please.
Also du kannst beispielsweise, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt zeigen will, bin ich ganz
sicher, ob ich da nicht irgendwas liege, aber Grafana kann, also wie gesagt, Grafana und
Prometos haben nix miteinander zu tun. Guck mal, die können standardmäßig AVS, Azure,
Elasticsearch, das ist übrigens Teil von Elk, Kibana, Logstash, Elasticsearch. Das
ist quasi die Konkurrenz dazu. Google Cloud, Influx DB, Graphite, Loki, Microsoft. Sekunde,
Sekunde, Sekunde. Ich finde das passende E-Mode gerade nicht. Aber wusste gar nicht,
dass er das kann. Wo ist das passende E-Mode? Ich habe so viele E-Modes, die ich nicht oft
verwende. Hier, passend, genau. Also du kannst auch MySQL abfragen, alle möglichen, Timeseries,
Database, Postgres, Prometos. Jager, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was Jager ist
oder Zipkin oder Tempo. Tempo habe ich glaube ich schonmal gehört. Aber was ist Jager?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, was Jager ist. Und was ist Zipkin? Zipkin klingt ein bisschen
wie Datenbank aus Co-Commonet-Land. Ich meinte nicht MySQL, ich meinte Microsoft SQL. Da
ist nichts Schlimmes dran, außer dass es Microsoft SQL Server ist. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was
es ist. Kann es auch XML? Nein, das Schöne ist, du kannst die Data Sources erweitern
mit Plugins und dann kannst du wahrscheinlich auch XML. So, da sind wir. Da haben wir unser
WSL am Start. Exzellent. So, erstmal root werden, immer das Allerwichtigste. Search,
können wir Wine installieren? Erstmal nachkucken. Jawoll, wir können Wine installieren. Gut,
das probieren wir nachher aus. So, jetzt mal schauen, das wichtigste. Lass mal überlegen,
was brauche ich denn immer so? Also, mal nochmal hier. Abinstall. Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall
schonmal T-Mags, ein Git. Wir können VS Code mal installieren. Und weil VS Code unter
Ubuntu ist ein Snap, oder? Moment, da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das überhaupt installiert.
Gibt es da nicht, oder? Das Gequarium gibt es da übrigens auch nicht. Aber gibt es da
C-Matrix? Ah, ok, das ist wichtig. Das brauchen wir erstmal. Also, eines der ersten Sachen,
die ihr installieren solltet unter Linux ist C-Matrix, dass ihr das hier machen könnt.
Euren inneren Hacker-Man erstmal starten. SL, nee. Hollywood auch, da weiß ich aber
nicht, ob die das dabei haben. Ah, haben sie. Auch, auch. Echt, man kann Code Plus machen
in WSL. Achso, ja klar, der kann ja mittlerweile Windows-Dinger starten, ne? Postchamp? Postchamp?
Pausechamp auf? Was macht der so lang? Crashed? Bestimmt, bestimmt gecrasht. Ach, mlocate,
das ist, der indiziert jetzt erstmal meine ganze Platte wahrscheinlich. Hätte ich das
mal lieber in einer T-Mark Session gemacht? Ich kann einfach Neues starten, das geht ja
wahrscheinlich. Der indiziert wirklich erstmal alles. Ich hoffe echt nicht, dass da über
Mount-Points drüber gehen, das wäre schon fair. Der indiziert jetzt gerade mal eine
ganze Festplatte anscheinend, ne? CPU? Ja gut, das ist Single-Threaded wahrscheinlich.
Ich könnte das einfach killen. Ok, also Code? Ok, also die Integration muss man ihnen echt
lassen, die Integration ist wirklich ganz gut gemacht. Ich mein, mir persönlich ist
es natürlich noch lieber, ich brauch die Windows-Seite davon einfach gar nicht. Dann brauch
ich auch die Integration nicht, aber wenn man Windows ein bisschen besser benutzbar
machen will, ist das hier schon mal ganz cool. Oh ne. Die haben den Sound, der Sound muss
weg. Haben wir den sein? Auch ein PowerShell? Ne. Also unter Linux die Hardcore-Variante,
um Speaker ruhig zu stellen, ist die hier, aber ich glaube, die geht unter VSL nicht.
Oder doch? Haha, Gebaided geht nicht. Ist immer noch da. Das ist normalerweise die brutale
Variante, einfach alles weg. VSL-Terminal-Beep, wie kriegt man den aus? Disable-Beep. Ah,
ok, das ist tatsächlich einfacher. Mixer. Easy. Haha, so kann man es auch machen. Binst
hier immer Toilet, das ist wichtig. Oh ne, geht ja nicht. Oh, er ist fertig. So, und
jetzt sagen wir Toilet-Echo-Gebaided. Bäm. Massive Kunst im Terminal. Die Musik ist richtig
klos jetzt, ne? So, also jetzt haben wir den Kram jetzt hin, sehr schön. Teamwork starten,
alles klar. So, ah, Moment, Moment, wir brauchen ordentlichen Vim. Nicht den Light Vim. Den
richtig echten. Am besten noch Vim, ne. Ge Vim. Vim GTK, volle Pulle. Komm, gib ihm alles.
Jawoll, Bäm. LOL-Cat, ja, das brauchen wir auch noch, klar. Ich meine, ich kann kein
GUI-Zeug starten, aber das ist das nächste, was wir uns mal angucken, ob man da irgendwie
GUI-Zeug drauf gestartet kriegt. Ja, klar, erkennt er, dass es nicht geht. So, wunderbar,
Vim. Ich bin froh, dass sie das hinbekommen haben mittlerweile, weil in der ersten Version
hatten die extreme Probleme mit den Vim-Escape-Sequenzen. Da bist du teilweise im Vim hängen geblieben,
konnte es nicht mehr raus. Also ja, wir installieren jetzt erstmal die wichtigen Dinger. Erstmal
die wichtigen Dinger. GWSL. Zeig mal her. Ups. Es gibt doch RDP, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
nicht RDPX. Oder wie hieß das Ding? RDPX, nee. XXRDP, nee. Nee, RDP logischerweise nicht.
Wie hieß denn das? Es gab doch, genau, VCXSRV, das Ding meinte ich, korrekt, korrekt. Aber
das sagt wahrscheinlich, wir probieren das hier aus. Microsoft Store. Get free, okay,
das probieren wir dann gleich mal aus. Aber jetzt erstmal das allerwichtigste Programm
überhaupt. Oder musste man da, musste man da, ah nee, da musste man irgendwas reinpipen,
ne. What is happening im Hintergrund, Alter? Das SL drauf. Okay, jetzt die wichtigste Kombination
überhaupt, SL, SLpipen nach LOLCAT. Haha, Windows Terminal ist broken an der Stelle,
sehr schön, sehr schön. Das funktioniert. Das Windows Terminal kommt mit den, kommt
mit den Escape Sequenzen nicht zurecht, wie es aussieht. Also ich kann es euch mal zeigen,
wie das eigentlich aussehen sollte, wenn man das ausführt. Haben wir schon das erste gefunden,
was broken ist. Machen wir mal in groß, vielleicht will es das im Fullscreen haben. Geht's
im CMD? Nein, nein, nein, im CMD geht's garantiert nicht. CMD mit ASCII Escape Sequenzen, hab
ich überhaupt kram installiert, jawoll. SL hab ich auch installiert. Jetzt kann ich euch
zeigen, wie es normalerweise aussehen sollte. Zwar, Aufzug, fahr durch. Man kann es übrigens
nicht abbressen. Bam. The Rainbow Train ist unterwegs. Sprichst du eine andere Fremdsprache
als Englisch? Nee. Ich hatte in der Schule mal Französisch ein bisschen, aber ich kann
kein einziges Wort Französisch. Frischarde. Doch, doch die Franzosen sagen anstatt Frischarde
die Frischarde. Das weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung, kann ich nicht. Ich hatte es auch nicht
lang. Ich kann Brötchen bestellen auf Portugiesisch. Das war's aber auch. Also im Prinzip, ich
kann nichts außer Deutsch und ganz brauchbar Englisch und Essisch. Das könnte tatsächlich
am TMUX liegen mit den Escape Sequenzen, das ist richtig. Nee, liegt nicht am TMUX. Aber
mittlerweile sollte die TMUX Geschichte eigentlich standardmäßig 32bit Farben können. In Wirklichkeit
kann ich natürlich Russisch, genau wie alle echten Hackermans. Nee, keine Ahnung. Also
ich kann, wie gesagt, ich kann nur Deutsch, bisschen Englisch, das war's. Gut, das funktioniert
schon mal. Standardmäßig, standardmäßig der Kram ist auch da. Hardtop und so, außer
dass die Farben ein bisschen off aussehen, ist auch okay. Die Farben sehen wirklich ein
bisschen verkehrt aus. Normalerweise sind die Farben so, ne? Hardtop, Lolcat. Funktioniert
sogar. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das geht. Das funktioniert sogar. Man kann das sogar
noch verwenden. Guck mal, das läuft sogar noch. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Mal gucken,
was Microsoft, was Windows da draus macht. Okay, das startet nicht mal. Das ist einfach
broken unter Windows. Probier es mal. Nee, Grip, vorbei. Keine Chance. Aber die Farben
sehen ein bisschen verkehrt aus in dem Windows-Terminal, muss ich sagen. Die sehen nicht wirklich
passend aus. Das stimmt irgendwas nicht. Ist halt die Fall-Seam. Nee, nee, nee, das stimmt
trotzdem nicht. Irgendwie als interpretiert er die Escape-Sequenzen nicht richtig. Deset,
Lolcat, kann er das? Ah, das kapiert er. Okay, das kann er. Ja, so sieht das gut aus.
Guck mal, massive Farbverlauf. Okay, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wir was Grafisches
zum Laufen kriegen. Was ich auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr nice finde, ist, dass ich beispielsweise
in Visual Studio Code meine Bash-RC editieren kann. Und das ist mein Visual Studio Code
aus Windows. Ja, installier mal. Nee, haben wir schon. Das ist mein Visual Studio Code
aus Windows, der jetzt im WSL-Attached ist. Das ist eine coole Geschichte. Okay, gucken
wir mal, wie wir grafische Sachen installiert bekommen. Beste grafische Test-App nach wie
vor X-Clock und X-Eyes. Ich finde übrigens, dass Copy-Paste im neuen Windows-Terminal
immer noch Paints-Champ. Warum geht keine mittlere Maustaste und warum geht nur dieser
komische Misch aus Rechts-Rechts-Klick, Doppel-Rechts-Klick. Ich meine Doppel-Rechts-Klick. Das kann sich
nur Microsoft ausdenken, sowas. Okay, wie richten wir da jetzt einen X-Server ein? Okay,
was ist da? GWSL-Install. Nehm nicht den komischen aus dem Store, warum nicht? Das ist der hier.
Oder kann man ja auch aus GitHub runterladen. Das ist recommended. Ey, wir machen das aus
dem Store, passt schon. Okay, let's do our Grafika. Wollen wir mal probieren, ob man das
einfach installieren kann und dann geht's. Ich hab ja meine Zweifel. Ich mach mal alles
wieder zu und installiere den Kram mal. Ich hab ja meine Zweifel, dass es einfach so geht.
Jetzt. Ich hätte am liebsten nicht Copy und Select, sondern mittlere Maustaste drücken
für Kopieren und dann einfügen gleichzeitig. Install. Nein, ich will keinen Microsoft-Account.
Sollte es so einfach installieren. Ich find's immer noch geil, wie das jedes Mal aufploppt.
Jedes Mal will mich Microsoft dazu gibaten, mich doch einzuloggen. So, schauen wir mal.
Einmal Rechtsklick ist Copy und das zweite Mal Rechtsklick ist Paste. Launch. Was passiert
der Mensch, der jetzt Launche? Aha. Yes. Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was passiert da
mit dem Uganda. Wie von Zulun. Aber da ist der Wim. Der Wim-Gründer engagiert sich da
schon seit über 10 Jahren für irgendwelche Projekte in Uganda. Hab ich schon öfters gehört,
da hat er auch schon Vorträge drüber gehalten. Also es ist kein Uganda-Meme oder so was,
er meint das ernst, ja. So, aber das ist cool. Was kann man sonst noch machen? Linux-Shell?
Ihh, das will ich nicht. Ist das denn gesetzt, wenn ich das hier aufmache? Das ist hier X-Ice.
Aha, das ist natürlich nicht gesetzt. Okay, wie kann ich das jetzt außer Shell starten?
Ich kann die hier natürlich aufmachen. X-Ice. Can't open display? Wait a minute. Wie bringe
ich jetzt Windows überhaupt bei? Moment, Taskbar. Wie bringe ich Windows bei, dass
der Kram da unten gefälligt... Moment, wie stellt man den Kram hier noch mal ein? Ah,
Windows, please. Was, du musst das ziehen? Echt jetzt? Ist das neu? Boah! Seit wann
geht denn das? Das ist ja big brain, Alter. Schon immer? Ich bin immer in das Config-Menü
gegangen und hab das eingestellt. Unglaublich. Okay. Distro-Tools. Auto-Export-Display. Ah,
X-Ice. Das ist tatsächlich äußerst nice. Auto-Export-Display. X-Ice. Jawoll! Leute,
wir haben das allerwichtigste Programm am Laufen. Seht ihr hier oben dieses komische
Windows-Logo, wo das nicht so ganz damit klar kommt, dass das... Das nicht so ganz damit
klar kommt, dass das irgendwie im Fenster ist. Damit kommt es überhaupt nicht klar.
Und es ruckelt. Guck mal, es ruckelt erst. Fuck. Und noch mal eine super High-Res-Uhr.
Okay. Das funktioniert tatsächlich. So, das heißt, jetzt kann ich hier grafische Sachen
starten. Das müssen wir gleich mal ausprobieren, wie gut das funktioniert. Wir installieren
jetzt mal Rider. Moment, Moment, Moment. Abinstall... Wir installieren jetzt einen Browser. Chrome.
By the way, geht, geht... Wenn ich jetzt Chrome... Das muss ich beides installieren. Wenn ich
jetzt Chrome installiere, ist es dann immer noch ein Snap? Ist es dann auch... Ist es
dann auch... GLX-Gears, ja. Bei GLX-Gears war das nicht Mesatools, genau. Edge... Moment,
gibt es... Aber es gibt doch Edge nicht im Paketmanager, oder? Nee, oder? Einer gibt's
nicht. Aber das muss ich downloaden. Soll ich einen Edge installieren? Okay, okay. Meine
Güte. Edge. Als erstes installieren wir uns jetzt mal Chrome. Ich will wissen, ob das
ein Snap ist. Weil Snap ist Paynes-Champ und es ist wahrscheinlich ein Snap immer noch.
Oder nicht? Ich kann nicht schreiben, Alter. Es ist kein Snap? Gbaited! Gbaited! Gbaited!
Ich installiere einen Chrome. Aber ob Snap da drauf läuft? Das müssen wir jetzt mal
ausprobieren. Nee, ne? Okay, Snap funktioniert nicht da drauf. Abinstallieren Firefox. Aber
Firefox wird funktionieren. Okay, dann installieren wir jetzt einen Edge-Browser. Das ist aber
wirklich komplett wie ein Edge im WSL. Aber ich meine, ernsthaft, wenn Firefox geht, wird
Edge auch funktionieren. Lord Folkermord, Paynes-Champ-Name. Das ist eigentlich schon
für den Prime-Sub. Starte mal GLX-Gears. GLX-Gears ist broken. Und mach meinen Rechner
glaube ich kaputt. GLX-Gears ist kaputt, Leute. Keine 3D-Beschleunigung. Super-Tux-Kart,
ne? Glaube ich nicht. Das wird auch nicht laufen. Über diesen X-Server. Nee, nee.
Wenn schon GLX-Gears nicht läuft. Wie hieß das Ding? GWSL. Aber wenn schon GLX-Gears
nicht geht. Smooth Frame Rate bei mir läuft das schon mal gar nicht. Stimmt, es ist ja,
ich hab ja auch noch VM in der VM, das kommt ja auch noch dabei. Das ist ja Doppels-Paynes-Champ-Bich.
Wir probieren das mal schnell aus. Das liegt an der VM. Das können wir tatsächlich mal
probieren. Ich schalte an die VM nochmal ausschalten. Und mal versuchen den 3D-Support einzuschalten.
Wo ging das nochmal? War das nochmal versteckt mit Display hier, ne? Nee, ist schon, ist
schon an. Aber das kann durchaus an der VM liegen. Das kann durchaus daran liegen. Ja,
man hat das heute nochmal installiert. Wie lange braucht der da dafür? Wird der immer
langsamer? Ich will das Super-Tux-Kart installieren. Massive-Paynes-Champ. Leute, wo wir gerade
dabei sind, der Preis, äh nicht der Preis-Champ, der Watt-Champ funktioniert wunderbar. Wer
den Watt-Champ nicht kennt. Wer den Watt-Champ nicht kennt. Ich hab mir was gebaut, um meinen
Stromzähler auszulesen. Das ist der Watt-Champ. Weil ich neuerdings meine Projekte alle irgendwie
mit Champ hintendran nenne. Wir haben oft, ich hab für die Arbeit eine Proxy-Auswertungstool
programmiert. Das nennt sich natürlich der Lock-Champ, was sonst. Und der funktioniert
jetzt wunderbar. Der hängt jetzt im Keller an den Stromzählern mit den Sensoren dran.
Das ist, äh, das ist ein Luftfeuchtigkeit-Temperatursensor. Das hier sieht man jetzt nicht. Das ist
ein Sensor, der blinkende LEDs erkennt für den Stromzähler oben. Und das ist ein Infrarotsensor,
der so eine Zählerscheibe erkennt. Funktioniert wunderbar. Und ich kann jetzt quasi sehen,
wie viel ich verbrauche im ganzen Haus. Und kann auch sogar Verbrauch voraussagen für
den Monat und sowas. Oder zumindest historisch kann ich dann sagen, hey, ergibt das irgendwie
Sinn, was ich gemessen hab und was die abrechnen und sowas. Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Der Watt-Champ champt vor sich hin. Das IntelliJ Zeug und WSL haben eigentlich recht guten
WSL Support. Ja, ich probier das mal aus gleich. Ich probier das gleich aus. Den Heiz-Champ,
den Heiz-Champ hab ich heute umsortiert. Dass der OK-Knopf oben ist. Ja, was heißt
ich? Eigentlich ist es ja so eine Mischung aus mir und Microsoft, die Paynes-Champige
Sachen machen. Da muss ich auch immer Monka essen. Wenn ich den Snap-Store... Ich find's
ja von den Ubuntu-Leuten schon ziemlich fail, dass sie das einem aufzwingen mit dem Snap-Store.
Oder was heißt aufzwingen? Dass sie das so versteckt machen. Installiert Chrome und
es ist ein Snap, obwohl du denkst, es ist ein echter Chrome. Der ist... Ja, ich weiß,
der ist Müll. Aber nein, das ist ganz so krass. Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Der misst
bei mir gerade 17 oder gestern 17 Grad gemessen und es waren, glaub ich, frag mich nicht 16
irgendwas. Aber der ist nicht genau und der Sensor ist langsam, aber 10 Grad plus minus
ist es nicht. Davon hab ich auch noch ne Menge. Davon müsste ich mal wieder, müsste ich mal
übrigens wieder welche bestellen, fände ich halt gerade. Warum ist Snap schlecht? Was
heißt schlecht? Ich find's doof, dass man durch den Package-Manager-Install, dass man
durch den Package-Manager-Install ein Snap-Paket installiert, wenn man ein normales Paket rechnet.
So ein bisschen teuer. Was kostet der Kram bei Ali? Was macht eigentlich der Suez-Kanal?
Ist er wieder frei? War das nicht von Bosch das Ding? Deswegen gibt's die nicht bei Ali.
Ist das Chip still stuck? Yes. Es ist schon geil, dass es dafür überhaupt Seiten gibt.
Ist das Chip still stuck? Yes. Zu geil. Alter, ist das ein fettes Ding, ey. Boah ey, das
ist ja ein megafettes Ding. Warum ist das eigentlich stuck? Das sieht doch gar nicht
so aus, als ist das großartig fest. Chipchamp, ja. Oh man. Das sind fünf Stück, ne. Gibt's
das nicht ein bisschen billiger, die Sensoren? Warum ist denn der preisliche Unterschied
hier so hart? Ah, weil das hier mehr Pins braucht oder was oder wie? Baker-Store. Hopp,
da hab ich noch nie was gekauft. Gibt's nicht. Gibt's nicht. Naja, Shipping 525 ist nicht
das Problem, wenn ich davon 10 Stück kaufe. Die gibt's bei Ali, deine Suche war kaputt.
Okay, was auch immer. Ich such mal unter Linux. Vielleicht mag da AliExpress besser.
Aber nach was habt ihr denn gesucht? 880. Der Chat hat wieder Mist geschrieben hier.
Was ist hier wieder los? Einmal verlässt du dich auf den Chat. Aber so viel billiger
ist es auch nicht. Eats Delivery. Ach, das ist ein BMP, das ist ein anderer. Temperatur
und Drucksensor. Was ist der Unterschied? BME, was ist BMP? Das braucht mehrere Pins,
das andere, der braucht Glock-Dings, Cloud VIN und der braucht was für Pins? Was ist
denn das? SCB und SCDings? Was sind das für komische Pins? Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich
das anschließen soll. Ach, kein Luftfeuchtigkeit. Na gut, aber davon bräuchte ich tatsächlich
auch mal wieder welche. Widmen wir uns mal weiter, WSL. So, SuperTuxCard. Geht das denn?
Oh, oh. Nein, SuperTuxCard läuft nicht. Das liegt da wahrscheinlich echt an meiner VM.
SuperTuxCard ist broken. Wahrscheinlich liegt es echt an meiner VM. Ich meine, ich hab
zwar schon den Gram aktiviert, aber es ist mit Sicherheit ein Unterschied, ob du VM-Ware
das über VM-Ware machst oder nicht. Ich meine, das ist ja im Prinzip jetzt doppelt
nested virtualisiert. So, dann probieren wir jetzt mal das. Also, ihr wollt ja, dass ich
Edge installiere. Erstmal gucken, ob Firefox funktioniert. Firefox geht, okay. Hey, ey,
ohne Scheiß. Okay, das ist jetzt fail, aber das fühlt sich tatsächlich sogar relativ
schnell an. Also, verhältnismäßig schnell. Muss man echt mal sagen? Hätte ich gar nicht
gedacht. Oh, nee, nee, nee. Oh, nee, es laggt. Ich hab nix gesagt. Es ist doch laggy. Ah,
ist doch ein bisschen laggy. Reine Software-Rendering jetzt. Aber ich mein, trotzdem cool, dass
es überhaupt geht. Ich mein, nicht schlecht, oder? Es ist ein Software-gerendertes. Okay,
komplett Fullscreen geht nicht. Okay, da ist schon ganz schön, ganz schön beschäftigt.
Aber ich mein, es ist ein 1440p60fps-Video. Der Ton? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Nee. Es kann
sein, dass man da Ton benutzen kann, aber da muss ich auf jeden Fall. Das ist jetzt
Firefox im WSL gehostet. Also, das ist Firefox, der im WSL läuft über einen X-Server unter
Windows. Ja, ja, genau. So sieht's aus. Paints-Champ. Okay, was soll ich runterladen? Was habt ihr
gesagt nochmal soll ich runterladen? Edge für Linux downloaden. Wirklich? Sollen wir
uns das wirklich antun, ja? In einer Windows-VM, genau. Kommt ja auch noch dabei, guckt mal.
30 Milliardenfach nestet virtualisiert hier. Wo gibt's den Download? Download Edge Linux
Ubuntu. OMG Ubuntu, alles klar. Go to Edge Download Page. Und wir downloaden den Edge,
wie sich das gehört. Oder was heißt, wie sich das gehört? Normalerweise gehört sich
das umgedreht. Man lädt Firefox mit Edge runter und wir laden jetzt Edge mit Firefox runter.
Was mich ja viel mehr interessiert ist, dass das ganze JetBrains-Gedöns funktioniert. Übrigens,
das will nicht, dass wir runterladen. JetBrains Toolbox brauchen wir. Die gibt's wahrscheinlich
standardmäßig nicht unter Ubuntu, oder? Hätte ich's mal im T-Max aufgemacht, dann
müsste ich jetzt nicht. Keine neue Session starten. Die default-Session muss ich übrigens
auch mal umlegen, dass das immer gleich ins Ubuntu geht. Die Toolbox ist da nicht dabei.
Hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert. Warum willst du das JetBrains-Zeugs in der VSL haben? Weil
ich, also wenn ich das mal an der Geschichte, wie wir es dann auf der Arbeit verwenden,
ich werde das so nicht verwenden, weil es einfach pains-champig ist. Aber wir bekommen
hier dann eine Windows-VM mit VSL drauf, wo wir aber unter Windows keine Admin-Rechte
haben, um was zu installieren. Aber wir haben komplette Admin-Rechte unter der VSL. Frag
mich nicht, wer sich das ausgedacht hat. Und ich kann dementsprechend auch keine.NET-Runtime
unter Windows installieren. Was kein Problem ist, die gibt es als ZIP und sowas. Die sind
gerade dabei, den Leuten wirklich das Arbeiten unmöglich zu machen. Deswegen bin ich froh,
dass ich das alles ein bisschen umgehen kann. Wenn ich im Homeoffice sitze, dann mache ich
das alles einfach hier auf meiner lokalen Linux-VM und lade es dann hoch, was ich brauche.
Richtiger pains-champ. Jetzt müsste wieder jemand im Chat schreiben, bei diesem Song
haben sich meine Eltern kennengelernt. Ne, bei diesem Song habe ich meine Eltern kennengelernt.
Das schreibt er immer bei diesem Song, wenn das läuft. Und ich sage dann jedes Mal, wie
oft willst du den Spruch noch bringen? Aber ich glaube, derjenige ist heute nicht da.
Als DAP runterladen. Accept. Jawoll. Save. Dann installieren wir das doch mal. Download.
Dann haben wir hier Debian. Äh, gibt sowas wie local install. Was ist das da? Ja, dpk
ig minus ig, das weiß ich. Einfach nur install. Ach so, Moment, Punkt, Slash. Ah, wow. Erstmal
das halbe Internet nachinstallieren. Das wusste ich noch gar nicht, dass das, ich glaube,
früher bei abget, musstest du es, glaube ich, local installen machen. Ich fasse es nicht.
Wir installieren ernsthaft, wir haben uns ernsthaft einen X-Server unter Windows in einer eh schon
doppelt nestet virtualisierten VM. Äh, ich kriege, ich, Moment, ich kriege gar nicht
mehr zusammen, um wie viele Ecken wir virtualisiert und gedingst haben. Einen Firefox dann mit
einem X-Server unter Windows haben wir uns jetzt Edge runtergeladen, installieren uns
Edge in einem WSL, was in einem Hyper-V läuft auf einer VM in meinem Windows. Mind blown,
Alter. Ihr dürft auf dem Windows kurken Software runterladen ausführen. Nein, dürfen wir nicht,
aber wir dürfen WSL verwenden und WSL Package Manager und sowas. Frag mich nicht, ist total
schwer. Ich werde es auch, ich werde damit gar nicht ordentlich arbeiten können. Ich könnte damit
beispielsweise letztens diese Proxy-Auswertung, die ich gebastelt habe, würde ich gar nicht
machen können. Sobald es wirklich akut wird, werde ich dann einfach bei jedem Auftrag, der kommt,
den ich nicht ausführen kann, das ins Ticket schreiben, würde ich sagen, ja, ich würde es ja
gerne machen, aber ich kann nicht, weil ich keine Rechte habe mit meiner VM. Worauf läuft die Windows
vor allem bald, aber das ist zu Tricks. SiteRikes ist das. SiteRikes. Aber es ist alles kein Problem,
ich hoffe, wir kriegen demnächst wieder ein stinknormales VPN, dann kann ich das einfach
von meiner lokalen Linux-Kiste daheim verwenden und wieder ganz normal arbeiten. Okay, wie starten wir
das jetzt? Edge. Microsoft Edge. Edge, da ist es. Bam. Wow. Da ist er, Leute. Oh fuck, jetzt habe
ich ihn zugemacht. Ein Microsoft Edge unter WSL, nested Edge. Es ist nicht sonderlich schnell,
aber es funktioniert. Ich sage es euch, die werden es auf der Arbeit so ätzend machen,
zu arbeiten, dass alle nicht mehr richtig arbeiten können, aus Security-Gründen und es wird dann
dazu führen, dass die ersten Leute anfangen sich heimlich zu tunneln, dass sie wieder arbeiten
können, was dann genau das Gegenteil bewirkt, was man mit Security eigentlich haben will.
Natürlich darfst du das nicht und ich werde das auch nicht machen, ich werde einfach jedes Mal im
Ticket nerven und sagen, kann ich halt nicht machen. Ich bin mal echt gespannt, wie das wird. Zumal,
wisst ihr was witzig ist, auf der einen Seite erzählen sie so nach dem Motto, die IT ist nicht
schnell genug, wir müssen agiler werden und dann baut man so Dinge auf, aber ihr kennt das
wahrscheinlich, es ist wahrscheinlich in jedem bisschen größeren Laden so und dann baut man
Hürden auf, die die Sachen standardmäßig schon und bei allem unnötig langsamer machen.
Das läuft nicht so gut wie im Firefox Leute, das ruckelt mehr als im Firefox. Zumal der Witz ist,
dass der Trend, der Trend geht ja eigentlich hin Richtung Bring your own device, ne. Okay,
das ist nice. So und jetzt kommt das und jetzt, okay, jetzt testen wir erst nochmal was sinnvolles.
Ich will nämlich mal die Jetbrains Sachen installieren und danach testen wir,
ob Wine ordentlich funktioniert. Wine unter Windows und dann führen wir Notepad aus oder so.
Die Jetbrains, die Jungs von Jetbrains. Oh, es funktioniert. Nein, nein, nein, not allowed.
Da ist der SSO, installieren wir mal eine Runde Rider. Hab es noch besser gemacht als so ein
Docker. Stimmt, stimmt, läuft ein Docker in WSL wahrscheinlich, oder? Übrigens Ubuntu ist
gebate. Docker ist falsch, ne. Wenn ihr Docker installiert, installiert ihr nicht Docker. Ihr müsst Docker IOU installieren oder ihr installiert direkt Docker Compose.
Gucken wir mal, was passiert, wenn ich das installiere. So, Rider. Hat er schon fertig installiert? Ah nee,
Installing. Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ging ja sonst brutal schnell, äh. Installing. Er downloadet
wahrscheinlich noch. Den schon fertig? Boah, ging ja mega schnell.
In der Microsoft Schulung wollten die mal, dass wir Docker für den, für Windows Desktop verwenden.
Das war richtiger Painschamp. Ich wollte, ich hab schon gedacht, ey, Linux Shell auf,
Docker, auf geht's. Und dann haben die ohne Scheiß zwei Stunden da rumgemacht,
bis die ein Windows Beklickgeschiss da installiert haben, in dem wir schon ordentliche Sachen machen
hätte können. Äh. Geht das jetzt? Wenn ich spreche, breche das mal kurz ab. Du musst
Docker den von Hand starten, oder was? Ach so, ja, ist okay. Hey, das funktioniert. Läuft. Ich kann
mich noch zur Docker Gruppe hinzufügen, dann wird es auch so. Aber geht. Äh, dann starten wir mal
ein Hello World Container. Da gab's doch Docker, dieses Docker Hello World. Wo gibt's das denn?
Äh, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das unter, unter Windows funktioniert. Ja, Docker run it. Jetzt
noch mal eine Ubuntu Bash, Alter, unter. Äh, Sudo. Jetzt ein Ubuntu Image im Docker noch,
ja. Und dann da drüber ein Wine, Alter. Funktioniert anscheinend, ja? Funktioniert?
Kann Docker unter VSL, das ist schon mal nice. So, und jetzt das Rider Zeug starten. Gucken,
wie gut das funktioniert. Ah, nee, wir brauchen erst noch eine.NET Runtime. Die hab ich ja noch
gar nicht installiert. Don't send. Nope. Äh, Dark Theme. Das läuft brauchbar schnell. Die
Schrift sieht kacke aus. Die Schrift sieht mega kaputt aus. Wahrscheinlich weil keinerlei
Schriftdaten installiert sind oder sowas. Not installed, not installed, ja, ich weiß.
Muss erst noch mal eine.NET Core installieren. Ah, hier sieht die Schrift jetzt okay aus,
okay. Äh, probieren wir mal. Haben die, haben die eine.NET Core standardmäßig dabei bei Ubuntu?
Die sind so dick, so dicke mit Microsoft, die haben doch da bestimmt was. Nee, oder? Haben
sie nicht? Hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht. Dachte, das sind Microsofts, Microsofts neue
best, best buddies. Aber die haben noch so ein installscript. Äh,.NET Core Linux install.
Na, als Snap installier ich das nicht, als Snap geht er nicht. Installieren von.NET unter
Ubuntu. Mithilfe des Scripts, jawoll. Wo ist das Script? Da. We get CRMOD plus X..NET install.
.NET install und er installiert standardmäßig 3.1. Man muss was machen? Minus C 5.0 minus C
current, genau. Was ist.NET? Äh, ne Runtime für C sharp, bushelbasic.net, F sharp. Was gibt's
noch so für Cobol.net? Wenn du Sachen in C sharp programmierst und es laufen lassen
willst, brauchst du eine.NET Runtime. Die kannst du zwar mit reinpacken, aber zu entwickeln
brauchst du die. Ok. Gucken, ob Ryder das jetzt erkennt. Hat er das jetzt in pass drinnen?
Iron Python, ja das gibt's auch. Das war die.NET, die.NET Python Variante von, von
ein paar Jahren. Es gab auch Iron, Iron Ruby und sowas. Ähm, weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt
jemand verwendet. Wüsste jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so wirklich warum. Ok, ein bisschen
laggy, ein bisschen laggy ist das schon, ne. Jetzt über, über das. Das könnte aber auch
an der VM liegen. So, äh, Toolsets und Builds. Wo konnte ich denn Kram jetzt nochmal auswählen
hier? Ja, komm mal, da hat's erkannt. Home.net. Alles klar, sehr gut. Save. Was? Can't wait.
Ich hab's kaputt gemacht. Es hat sich aus irgendwelchen Gründen gerade gecrasht, das
hab ich noch nie gesehen. Ich wusste, ich wusste gar nicht, dass da gerade, also ohne
Scheiß mir ist Ryder noch nie gecrasht. Und das obwohl's Java Kram ist. Was übrigens
eigentlich auch richtiger Pains Champ ist, wenn man sich's mal genau überlegt, ne. Ähm,
wir entwickeln quasi.net Programme mit ner Java IDE. Wird die dann dynamisch skaliert,
das ist ne gute Frage. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt kein blassen Schimmer. Native Keychain. Ja,
ich brauch keine Passwörter drin. Das ist schon fucking laggy gerade hier drum, das,
das, das zu benutzen. Ich warte mal, bis der alles indiziert hat und so. Ich warte mal,
bis der fertig indiziert hat, wie sich's dann bedienen lässt. Ryder ist besser als
Visual Studio. Ich muss sagen, ich hab mich da mittlerweile so dran gewöhnt, dass ich
standardmäßig Dornett-Projekte auch komplett nur noch unter Linux mache mit Ryder. Ich
könnte auch Ryder unter Windows installieren, aber warum. Okay, er ist fertig. Das, oh fuck
Alter. Okay, das ist nicht benutzbar. Ich hoffe, das liegt an meiner VM. Oh shit. Das
ist, okay, das ist nicht benutzbar. Das ist laggy wie Sau. Guck mal hier, ich drück
den Knopf. Seht ihr das, wie lang das dauert? Jetzt hat das Enter sogar gefressen komplett.
Boah, nee, das ist laggy wie Sau, das kann man nicht verwenden. Wir brauchen Stadia mit
negativ Latency dafür, ja. Mal gucken, ob ich das Programm wenigstens ausführen kann.
Wie viel RAM hat die voll? Ich glaub 8G. 8G. Okay, aber es funktioniert wenigstens. Nee,
aber so kann man nicht arbeiten, ohne Scheiß. Also so kann ich nichts entwickeln. Boah,
das ist pains, pains, champic. Meine Fresse, nee, das geht nicht. Exit. Kann man Ryder
nicht per SSH Attachement wie Visual Studio Code? Ja, ist schon möglich. Bringt mir nichts,
ich hab ja kein anderes Ryder. Also dann, wie gesagt, die Möglichkeit hab ich da schon,
aber wenn ich nur die von der Firma zur Verfügung gestellten Mittel verwenden würde, dann nicht.
Also das ist eklig. So, Cottencory Gaming, nee, einfach nur Cottencory, The Prime Gaming,
WTF, Big Low Brain von mir hier. Danke für den Sub, 6 Monate. Woop, POG, richtig, richtig
Massive POG. Geht in WSL, ZSH mit Plugins, klar, das funktioniert, das muss schnell ausprobieren,
das funktioniert auf jeden Fall. So, jetzt kommt das Interessanteste. Abinstall Wine.
Es gibt Wine und Wine Stable. Ohne es gibt Wine64, bin es hier nicht das normale Wine.
So, und jetzt starten wir Notepad im Wine. Das muss ich unbedingt mal ausprobieren. Und
Dogger können wir mit abschießen hier an der Stelle. Darauf hat die Welt gewartet, Notepad
laufen zu lassen im Wine über WSL mit einem Xsofer auf Windows in a VM mit nested Virtualisierung.
Das musste sein. Dazu kann ich tatsächlich plus sagen, Moment, ich warte, ich warte,
bis es startet. Warum nicht Notepad++? Können wir auch ausprobieren. Wartet mal, Notepad++,
das lade ich einfach runter und starte das gleich mit Wine, das geht bestimmt. 32 Bit,
Copy Link. Ah, das ist ein Installer, ich brauch das Standalone, Portable. Gibt es nicht
als Standalone, gibt es nicht als Standalone Xso oder so? Portable, Zip. LCD, Downloads,
WGet und Zip. Oh, ich hasse diese Zips. Leute, fuckt euch das auch ab, wenn ihr Zips habt,
die sich nicht in eigenen Ordner entpacken, sondern in dem Ordner, wo ihr drin seid. Okay.
Upt, install, was? Upt, get, install, Wine32, okay. Das mache ich gleich noch. Wine32 ist
missing. Sag mal, ist das eine Endlosschleife oder ne? Ich installe noch Wine32, ja. Installierst
du gerade Wine? Ja, mache ich. Mache ich. So, einfach nur just for fun ausfunktioniert.
Wine64 haben wir jetzt. Ne, Moment, was? Es gibt Wine und Wine64, Wine32 gibt es gar
nicht. Jetzt haben wir aus irgendwelchen Gründen noch WineStable. Okay, ne, ich glaube, Notepad++
kriegen wir nicht zum Laufen. Was, Moment, was sollen wir machen? Ich glaube, das funktioniert
in WSL nicht, oder? Okay, Windows ist wieder PaintsChamp beim Copypasten. Oh, Moment,
das muss ich natürlich als Studio machen, sonst wäre das nichts. Ey, das wird nicht
funktionieren, Leute. Das glaube ich nicht, dass das funktioniert. Ja, oder auch nicht.
Sag bloß, das funktioniert. Sag bloß, das funktioniert. Ich muss mal danach gucken,
wie groß danach meine WSL install ist. Wahrscheinlich ist die Platte gleich voll. Okay, zeige ich
mal her. Auf, gib Gas, 14 Sekunden. User ist nicht Champ, ne, habe ich nicht dran gedacht.
Du hast recht, normalerweise nenne ich ja alles irgendwie Champ. Ich hätte eigentlich den
User auch Champ nennen müssen. LoginChamp. Boah, das ist ja fast so viel wie npm installen,
was er hier macht. Das ist auch das halbe Internet, was er installiert. WSLChamp, genau.
Okay. Okay Leute, meint ihr es geht? Chat, wer hat noch Punkte für eine Abstimmung?
Haben wir Mods da? Mod check? Haben wir Mods da, die eine Abstimmung machen können? Wird
es laufen? Ja, nein. Ihr braucht keine Punkte ausgeben, ich mach die Abstimmung auch so.
Ihr müsst nicht keine Punkte ausgeben, das passt schon. Nicht am PC. SeriousMax, weißt
du wie das geht? Ich hab das einmal gemacht und steig da noch nicht so richtig durch.
Genau, da hier. Die Vorhersage hat begonnen. Prediction. Also, wie wird es laufen? Man
muss eingeloggt sein oder wie oder was? Also es prediktet gerade, ja 93%, nein 7%. Ihr
seid aber äußerst zuversichtlich, dass das funktioniert. Ich kann übrigens selbst nicht
abstimmen. Okay, 88% ja, 12% sagen nein. Okay. Postchamp? Ha!
Ha! Unknown exception occurred, file not found. Bam! Bam! Wow! Punktiert nicht. Ach du Scheiße!
Das sieht nicht gut aus. Nope. Nein, keine Chance. Das läuft nicht. Kann man Notepad
launchen? Aber Notepad läuft immerhin, aber Notepad++ läuft nicht. Also Leute, wir haben
es geschafft, wir haben ein Notepad laufen. Kein Notepad++, die Umfrage gegen Notepad++,
ne? Wir haben Notepad im Wine, im WSL, nestet virtualisiert in der VM. Das ist überhaupt
so lackfrei läuft, ist schon der Witz. Das läuft ziemlich gut. Paint? Ne, ich glaube
Paint ist da nicht dabei. Oder doch? Was kann man noch mal schnell ausprobieren? Kann
ich mein Internetexperiment herunterladen? Now with Bing. Achso, jetzt habe ich den Downloads
gar nicht drinne. Kann man da Sachen reinkopieren ins WSL? Quasi sowas hier. Ach, das ist ein
Installer. Okay, das wird nicht funktionieren. Das wird nicht, nein. Ach, reinkopieren kann
man nix, Dragon Droppen, oder wie? Na, das funktioniert natürlich nicht. Da muss ich
jetzt nach Mount, C, User, Test, Downloads, probieren das jetzt? Wie heißt da Kram? Stimmt,
ich hätte einen Explorer aufmachen können, ja. Aber das wird nicht funktionieren. Das
wird nicht funktionieren, auch mit Wine nicht. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass man EE
anzeigen kann? Nein, Anzeige ist raus. Wine CFG, Windows Version umstellen. Windows 7,
das müsste eigentlich funktionieren. Und jetzt? Postchamp? Nein. Nope, keine Chance,
das kriegen wir nicht installiert. Na gut, aber das war jetzt noch mehr Spielerei, dass
Kram funktioniert mit Wine oder nicht. Aber ist eine coole Sache. Also ich muss sagen,
man kann es benutzen und wenn man Windows verwenden muss und wenn man irgendwie eine gute Integration,
also wirklich zwischen echtem Windows Programm und Linux Programm braucht, ist es auch wahrscheinlich
das einzig Notwendige. Ich persönlich, muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich bevorzuge immer noch
meine klassische Linux VM und gut ist. Echt, ZFS wirft R aus, kann man gar nicht vorstellen.
Aber trotzdem, cooler Versuch auf jeden Fall. Leider, leider, was ich persönlich ein bisschen
doof finde, ist, dass Rider quasi gar nicht funktioniert. Also was heißt gar nicht, doch
es funktioniert, aber es funktioniert nicht gut. Moment, ich hab doch gar kein Chrome installiert.
Das debatet mich. Und SuperTuxKart geht auch nicht. Okay Leute, ich hab Hunger, ich geh
jetzt essen. Massive. Massive Pippo Fett. Und ist da Frazier da oder so, den ich hosten
kann? Nope. Kein Frazier am Start. Was, doch, da ist er. Da ist er. Warum wird der bei mir
nicht als Online angezeigt? Der Frazier. Raid. Wir raiden den Frazier. Auf gehts Leute. Wir
sehen uns dann im nächsten Stream, ich hab übelst Hunger, ich muss jetzt was futtern.
Machts gut, wir sehen uns, bis dann, see you.